um
[Laughter]
hey you guys it's wednesday evening oh
i'm glad we didn't have the same shirt
on because i just went and changed
shirts and i didn't ask you which
t-shirt you had on i just would have got
up and changed
i'm not scared because sometimes i take
my shirt off
start swinging it around yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah because sometimes we
turn up and it's like if i haven't like
noticed what you were watching and i was
like oh [ __ ] we have the same t-shirt on
we don't think about it we got a closet
full of shirts
well yeah and like i said we have a lot
of the same ones because we because we
make a lot of them so you know what i
mean they're like our work shirts yeah
we're wearing them all the time when
we're in the house [ __ ] working on
[ __ ] or just watching [ __ ] going on a
store
we did without even thinking about it
now yeah some of our shirts that like
that when we made that for somebody else
isn't that yeah this one is that one
absolution yeah absolution yeah
that's the gothic festival in tampa
which is coming up again they're they're
doing it this year yeah they want me to
make the next year it's uh
october 7th 8th and 9th which is a
thursday friday and saturday actually
it's not the absolution shirt that they
want they want me to do the um communion
after the union
yeah yeah for the show for their show
for their radio show yeah let's see
who's here
sandra has a sad uterus yeah
[Laughter]
i don't know how that should happen all
of our uteruses are aside
see who else is here
bee's nest is in there
he's on the phone
okay well don't let it don't let us
interrupt you telling us yeah yeah i'm
on the phone we're boring yeah
okay
you guys don't interrupt me i'm on the
phone
she's driving home she'll catch it when
she gets home
she's driving home
[Laughter]
all right dj maniac says that we had a
club night here in new in new york city
called the uh that back in the day
so what like apple's absolution probably
probably yeah i think that's probably
where they got the name from yeah
it was really good when we went it was
probably i think it was two years ago
right because they didn't do one last
year yeah um
but yeah it's three days and
you know all kind of bands
and all the bands are printed on the
back
and badgers is asking if we're moving if
the landlord gets a boot i guess he
missed the other show oh yeah well
that's the thing it's like i didn't know
how much of it we should go back into
again because i know not everybody
listens to all our matinee shows yeah um
so we did say like on sunday what had
happened but we'll probably get into it
on here too because i did actually kind
of start
cleaning stuff out in here and yeah he
needs this house because he's getting
too old to go up and down the stairs
yeah and their house was two-story yeah
so um
they're uh giving us they want to swap
houses with us yeah essentially they're
trading houses no increase in anything
got two months to make the move because
they got a bunch of houses it's like
this one is two stories it's 50 larger
yeah it's a thousand square feet bigger
than this one and has one more bedroom
and one more bathroom and what and
another and it also has another living
room
that's right you've got another living
room upstairs yeah and um it's got two
living rooms downstairs a dead and
[ __ ] kitchen it's got you know it
it's a big it's much bigger than this
house yeah it's gonna be the ac [ __ ]
bill's gonna be higher but it's still
worth it i guess but it's only 10 10
miles up the road towards eustis it's
back
i like it up there it's getting it's
getting too gentrified up in this [ __ ]
well they're building like well like i
said we've said this on the show before
but when we moved here like what was it
like 10 years ago or whatever this
wasn't like rural rural but it was right
on the edge of rural yeah uh but since
we've lived here they've built like new
housing complexes new uh townhouses oh i
forgot to talk all kind of restaurants
road out here at the back gate yeah do
you know what you hear all that noise
yeah you know what they're doing what
are they doing they widened that
really like walking that road today holy
[ __ ] that was now that was
wow all four lines imagine that i would
have gone out my car and been like what
the [ __ ] where am i so it's time for us
to go
it's time for us to go they they're
putting in [ __ ] stop lights and all
kinds of [ __ ] it's looking too civilized
here
and this is going to be uh this is going
to be uh
suburbia
well it already is suburbia now yeah i
mean because like i said there was a lot
of serbia when we moved there was some
stuff when we moved here like i think
that walgreens up around the corner that
was here and i think there was like some
restaurants and [ __ ] but it's like since
we've been here they built a hotel a
bank a mcdonald's
um like they uh i think a starbucks like
down the thing they built like just tons
and tons of stuff
and down like a mile from us they're
also building another on-ramp to the
highway
so that's like a big [ __ ] down
there so
i mean the houses they're building are
like really nice they're like half a
million dollar houses yeah but there's a
lot of them and they're building a lot
of them actually you know at the end of
the path that i walk on they're building
a house up there they're gonna build a
bunch of [ __ ] there it's it's gonna lose
10 lots it's losing that
semi-rural charm that it had it's now be
coming to the suburbs and you know
there's big housing complexes and stuff
within a couple miles that are going up
it's just
it's too civilized man and where we're
going is 10 miles up the road it's uh on
the edge of eustis which i've lived
there before lived in that area but it's
grown up there too
it's now over there like it used to be
here 10 years ago when we when we moved
here yeah i mean the house we're going
to it's in a neighborhood like this one
yeah it's all the same it's not gated
like it doesn't have which is fine with
me because that was always kind of a
pain in the ass to be honest with you
because every time somebody would come
over to visit you'd have to call the
front gate and like tell the people
their name and what time they were
coming
up over there that's good that's going
to go go there too though yeah i know
because it's got a housing commission
they'll put they'll i mean they like i
said they have a big sign out front and
everything like that what is the what
the hell's the name of it bear brook or
bear brook i think creek or bear
it was high-end country housing yeah
when it was built it's the same age as
this one it looks just like
it looks like houses on this street
looks like it was made by the same
company uh it may have been
they look like they've been kind of been
made although that's just kind of like
the style they build houses nowadays
yeah different companies
it's the same age as this
he wants the same as this one but it's
50 percent larger
yeah he offered to sell it to me which i
might buy we'll see eventually when we
have something we'll see but yeah he's
offering it to us for the same rent even
though it's
five bedrooms three and a half bath yeah
no this one's only four or three and
it's a thousand square feet bigger than
this one yeah
and it has two floors and it has two
stories this is only one story yeah
saunders says it's kind of ugly on the i
don't think it's ugly the outside i
think it's better looking than the front
of this house you think so yeah it's got
a single door it needs a double door
i don't know i'm not like i said i'm not
i'm not super picky about it i grew up
in a [ __ ] trailer park and it's like
somebody somebody wants to give you like
a really really nice house from well
it needs two doors you're gonna be like
all picky about it it's like i don't
understand that at all saunders is gonna
furnish it though
yeah well we'll do it a little bit at a
time all right sandra said you can't
move because path kitty i was just gonna
say path kitty aka mr maguire i have not
seen him for
more than two weeks that's somebody's
house cat now and i think what happened
because it looked like because like i
said for a long time i was bringing him
food and stuff like that because he was
too skinny and other people on the path
were taking care of him too so like the
last time i think i was walking
yesterday and so like i had a couple
people ask me like i haven't seen him
around and i think what happened because
somebody had started taking care of him
like somebody looked like they'd taken
him to a groomer because he was all
clean and combed and all his little
wounds were fixed and he was kind of
chubbing out he's not fat but he was
just like regular cat's eyes so i think
what happened was they're just like not
letting him go outside anymore but like
even before that it happened like i was
seeing him less often like a lot of
times i'd only see him like i used to
see him every day
but then for a long time i was only
seeing like maybe once a week
and then
now i haven't seen him for like two
weeks yeah yeah it's five bedrooms
[ __ ] three living rooms
yeah there's a living room upstairs
right like a big yeah kind of big lounge
area and then there's three bedrooms and
two baths upstairs and then there's a
bedroom and
a bathroom downstairs and a half bath
downstairs and then there's like a
living room and i think there's also a
great room yeah like i said we were
gonna go see the inside today but a
thousand feet dude it's a thousand feet
bigger than this one yeah it's a
thousand square feet bigger than this so
it's it's gonna be it's like thirty five
hundred
thirty five hundred square feet tall
it's a huge house
it's and i think it's a big mansion and
i think this one is 2 400. yeah and this
one is
yeah so that one's that one's 20
this one's for this one's four bedroom
three bath this one doesn't have a half
bath right he said you can put a prepper
room for all your [ __ ] weapons and
ammo actually one there's going to be a
but there's going to be offices going to
be a studio
going to have a second one there's going
to be break room for the show because
we're doing the show so i can make stuff
there's i'm probably going to put a gym
in there
yeah i think one of the bedrooms is just
going to be a gym like i'm going to get
you know an exercise bike you got your
weight sets we can put that in there
because then you don't have to like go
out in the garage or yeah
i have stuff to do to decorate
two living two living rooms down yeah i
guess i can decorate two living rooms
and i did with what i have already
because we have two small living rooms
and den the way it is now yeah
so it just we just need a little bit
more it's not gonna matter i'm not real
i kind of like empty space i don't like
cluttering up a house filled with
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh i mostly just like artwork and [ __ ]
and chairs and stuff that does stuff
but um it's gonna be it's gonna look
cool
yeah i'm excited about it like i said i
already kind of picked out because you
know if you weren't here sunday we said
we're going to go see the inside friday
and they're going to give us the keys
yeah then we have two months and then we
have two months to move so they said
they said yeah they said you can take
your time just like move [ __ ] over there
like a little bit at a time you can
paint it whatever right um
carpeting
yeah they just paint i think well the
the only the second floor has carpeting
the first floor is all is all tile which
is nice because
i honestly it's like if if i could pick
and if i had a house built i would have
zero cars yeah just all the time um
because i'm styling wood floor i'm not a
fan
of carpet
but this one it's just the upstairs has
carpet
so
but we'll see
we'll see how it goes
uh one of the living rooms can be a goth
bar with dope sound and lights we're
actually probably gonna do probably put
a bar in it the upstairs uh living room
lounge area i think since my office is
going to be upstairs i think we're just
going to make that a combined
like hangout room bar
coffee station you know what i mean so i
don't necessarily if i just want coffee
or a snack or something i don't have to
like be going up and down the stairs
in there yeah we'll have like a mini
fridge and [ __ ] like that so you know
what i mean maybe a microwave
big tv so we can like make popcorn and
[ __ ] like that so we like sit up there
and watch movies and
that'd be kind of neat because like i
said then i wouldn't really
necessarily i could just go and make
coffee right you know in the morning and
just go right to my office
yeah so we're getting it before the
[ __ ] rents go sky high everybody's
[ __ ] moving here
yeah and like i said they're building
new houses all the way they're building
houses and [ __ ] everybody's moving
here
from new york and california i just
noticed that they were building a house
because remember i said up at the end of
the path up at 46. yeah that's that road
is 46. where the end of the path where
the turnaround is um they were selling i
think was it 10 lots maybe it was just
five lots but they were selling like
lots back there because it was all empty
and because remember there's that like
oh really old like wooden house that
they're kind of dismantling like one by
one and i looked back there and they're
building a house back there on one of
those lots and what's funny is that i
lived like a couple miles from where i'm
where we're at like in 2008 2009 when i
was [ __ ] working in the [ __ ] horse
industry i was living yeah it's out
where all the horse farms here and it
was there was hardly anything out there
other than farms and like [ __ ] houses
now there's [ __ ] sushi bars and
[ __ ]
restaurants and there's an amc there
they just built a nice new publix
grocery store
it's like right up the street which is
nice yeah the cut so it's lost a lot of
its [ __ ] ruralness it's more like but
it's on the outskirts now yeah i mean
the thing about it though it's like i
didn't i wouldn't have my like i didn't
mind because as soon as they said hey we
want to trade houses hey you want this
like much bigger kind of nicer house
like for the same rent i was like yes
please okay
um
the only thing i was worried like we
drove out there i'm like wow this is
kind of out you know it's not you know
what i do when we drive out to my mom's
house yeah you drive out to like okay
it's not like that bad no um so i'm kind
of where i'm like wow this is kind of
rural out here but then it looked like
they've built a lot of stuff like in the
last few years yeah convenient stuff
around there yeah so it's not like
you're totally out in the middle of
nowhere and there's no [ __ ] right
because my mom's house um half the time
you can't even get a cell phone signal
right
that's how far out in the [ __ ] her
mom's almost out in the forest well it's
ocala national forest they have 10 acres
and the like there's other houses around
there and there's like a convenience
store and a gas station like up on the
corner
you know they're not like out there and
there's no one around do they but do
they even have internet they do but it's
really really slow right um and it
depends like sometimes you can get cell
service out there like sometimes i've
taken my phone out there and you could
kind of get like one bar
but most of the time i can't get a
signal yeah they are they are [ __ ]
what they call off the grid which is why
i really really don't like driving out
there and it sucks i don't really like
driving out there to see her because i'm
kind of like especially not by myself
because i'm like i'm not driving all the
[ __ ] way out in the middle of the
forest and no cell phone service and get
a [ __ ] flat tire my car break down on
the way back in the dark [ __ ] that he
had that house built
from scratch
and it he built it yeah he built he's a
contractor yeah it looked like a dab
horseshoe with the [ __ ] enclosed in
the middle it's kind of like horseshoe
shaped i guess are u shaped with a big
swimming pool in the middle and [ __ ]
fountains and
it's got it's all screened in so well
it's essentially two houses two hectares
combined with when he built it um his
mother was still alive
uh and she moved down here to florida
she lived somewhere no i guess she lived
in south to me it almost looked like a
hotel
yeah well so they built like so they
built like their house and then they
then there's like the pool and the big
screened in thing and then attached like
right across the patio is another
smaller house
um that his mom used to live in
uh but she died so i don't think anybody
is in there now yeah um but my stepdad
is i don't think he's doing too
well i'm not sure how old he is he's
significantly older than my mom
yeah it's pretty nice though for out in
the country i mean literally it's a nice
house the world could end and i don't
think it would have a big impact on that
[ __ ] house you'd have to no probably
not you'd have to do
power production that'd be it if you had
your own generators in your own field
you'd never know that the world ended
because it's it's got its own water and
it's got its own septic
you just have to and that you could
literally live
just hunting the [ __ ] local game
grow in a farm yeah because like i said
they're right in the they have 10 acres
and there's animals all around there
um
so and they and they have and they my
mom has like a garden as well like she
grows all kind of vegetables and stuff
even if it lost power you could still
survive in there
yeah just be miserable well they have
they have a generator actually i think
they have more than one generator
you know yeah gram through said uh did
you warn the landlord about the ghost in
your house the ghost will come with us i
was gonna say uh the ghost is that's
that's your [ __ ] that'll it'll follow us
to the to the next house
[Laughter]
what are you drinking today
uh so i don't know if he's asking us or
just the chat in general
i have coconut vodka and orange juice
esther says super chat aka the tom and
jenny new home fundraiser yeah it's like
i said it won't really like
it's nice because we won't really have
that many moving costs because they're
letting us move a little bit at a time
um
it's not like we have to leave it it's
not like we have to like pack all our
[ __ ] into like one big truck we can just
take most of the [ __ ] over like in the
car yeah and then maybe rent a van for
one day just for the bigger [ __ ] and
like i said we don't have a ton
of big furniture and honestly this
office furniture this massive [ __ ]
desk is not even mine like i said it was
your stepdad's and i just kind of
inherited it yeah
we're not taking that though and i'm not
taking it i don't it's ugly and it's
massive and it's old and it's hard to
move around
um so i'm just gonna get like
some new
[ __ ]
and i'm and those bookshelves back there
i've had those those gray ones are from
ikea and i bought those
12 years ago and they kind of got wet
like part of them got wet and they're
kind of the only thing holding them up
is all the [ __ ] on them if i take all
the books off they will they will
collapse to one side
just i put all the heavy [ __ ] on the
bottom leg so they wouldn't fall over so
yeah so i'm gonna get new bookshelves
and new desks and stuff like that but
other than that we don't have a [ __ ] ton
of stuff so i just today i started
cleaning
the closet right here in the office out
and just
i ordered a bunch of boxes so i started
just like packing [ __ ] up slowly grandpa
says he's got 23 solar panels coming up
on top of his roofs in a couple of weeks
he's going to be off the grid
that's good
biesner says i'll send a housewarming
gift okay
[Laughter]
well thank you yeah he showed me instead
of you he sent you some uh some uh stuff
from mexico yeah i saw him send you a
picture she sent me a picture she sent
me pictures
so i was kind of like yeah i'm excited
about it i'm excited about it but yeah
i'm just i don't know i'm just i'm
really excited about it i we we keep
telling pookie
yeah they're gonna trip about she's only
known this house yeah because we got her
when she was little when she was
six weeks old eight weeks old she was
little her eyes were still blue
and she i mean she was a little bitty
tiny thing
we got her like
wasn't it that lady like found her and
found her in her backyard or something
or that was the story
everything that woman said turned out
not to be and then she was keeping
pookie
who was a tiny tiny kitten she was like
keeping her in a like a little cage or
something like that like in
her garage because she had a bunch of
dogs and she thought that the dogs would
hurt the kitty
and i guess it's like she heard that we
were looking for a cat and a kitten so
sent us a picture and of course once we
saw the picture we were kind of like yep
we're just gonna have to have them we're
gonna have to have that kitty
[Laughter]
and who knew that pookie would turn out
the way she turned out the cat's a trip
what a crazy kitty she is all right so
let's go ahead and start the show off
well i thought we already did this is
this is a side track yeah um
what's been going on today uh if you
guys have any questions you guys can uh
go ahead and answer ask him in the
in the comment section and we'll address
that [ __ ]
yeah philbert grimm says i got a desk on
amazon for fifty four dollars real nice
one at that yeah the one i was looking
at um
i think is 70 but i'm gonna get like a
couple of them because i i have like
three computers
we have i have this streaming computer
my graphic design computer and then this
computer that i just kind of is general
use so i kind of want two or three of
them so each one can have like its own
station type of thing um because i got
to set up different microphones
like my graphic design computer i use
that for
um recording audiobooks
and for that that's like a different
microphone than this so i want to have
that one like with the other microphone
the scarlet solo or whatever it's called
like hooked up all the time
and i don't know i got i got a whole
plan in place at least for the office
i don't know what we're gonna do with
the rest of the [ __ ] bees nest who's uh
one of my uh [ __ ] trt [ __ ]
brothers he's in there talking to sandra
sandra whose guy has unhappy uterus i
don't know maybe maybe she hit menopause
or something sad uterus sad uterus but
he's in there telling her about trt
she's gonna say you're gonna go i guess
go to the doctors she
see if that he'll give it to her you
know but
that's germany and here here in florida
they have hrt or hormone replacement
therapy clinics
that uh
some of them
will do both men and women most of them
will just do just men all right
and it's because the female system is
more complicated we're too complicated
to even deal with
she's trying to be funny i am funny
um the
uh
it's a lot harder to give a woman hrt
and to maintain fertility
okay
most women do not want to become
infertile
all right
now
if if you've already reached menopause
it's a lot easier because you there's
you're not trying to maintain for
fertility
if you're young and you don't mind
temporarily losing fertility by doing
that kind of stuff you'll just stop
having your period
okay you you can start it back up later
but everything that goes along with
the female
hormonal profile
has to come back
you cannot run testosterone in a
in a young fertile woman
and not have her body
reacts to that
it will react by she'll become more
athletic she'll lose a lot of body fat
she'll get a lot leaner and more
muscular it look it looks good okay it
doesn't look it doesn't look masculine
as long as you understand the doses
uh but she will stop her period
now she's an athlete she'll come up hot
on all those damn performance
enhancement tests so an athlete can't do
it unless she's in a sport
that allows for
hormonal modifications and most of them
don't
unless it's some kind of open class
sport like open class bodybuilding and
bodybuilding or if she's just a fashion
model or
she just doesn't give a [ __ ] and just
wants to look like a damn superhero
like a marvel superhero then she can
just take test testosterone
a woman's main hormone is testosterone
it's not
estrogen that's a pregnancy thing it's
testosterone it's just that it's usually
one-tenth of what a man's is
normally if you bump her up a little bit
higher than that
starts kind of
changing their the way they're built
changes uh what they call a body
composition they gain muscle and lose
fat
um
if you go up too high
you start giving male doses to a woman
over time
she will grow into a man
okay
indistinguishable girl
you'll be a man soon
[Music]
takes time
but literally they'll be
indistinguishable until the pats come
off and you go you're not a you're not a
[ __ ] it'll be a crying game moment yeah
it'll be a crying game moment spoiler
alert in case you haven't seen the
crying game
that's an old-ass movie
[Laughter]
camp guy said i used to do rudimentary
graphic design for my.com website back
in the late 1990s i actually graduated
from graphic design school in
95 i want to say
but i've you know i've been doing it for
a long time so
i had to like keep up with it uh then
he's saying using coreldraw holy [ __ ] i
worked in a t-shirt shop that used
they used coreldraw i think that's the
only place i ever had to use it most
places back in the old days
back in the 90s um most publishing
houses and all that kind of stuff which
is normally what i worked for i worked
for mostly publishing
newspapers magazines stuff like that and
then
direct mail for a little while they
almost all used quark
uh or indesign uh but coreldraw yeah but
and like i said they would usually use
the adobe [ __ ] because you know we had
to learn illustrator and all that kind
of stuff
which
you know that's still what i use
nowadays i use illustrator
and photoshop for pretty much everything
i i still use indesign for book layouts
but that's pretty much the only thing i
use for that esther says jenny i finally
watched the invitation isn't that movie
awesome i love that movie uh i liked it
and i rewatched the perfect toast i re i
need to watch that because
we were talking about that earlier like
dinner party kind of horror and she said
that was a really good one and i hadn't
seen it it has that guy from frasier on
it right
because i keep seeing the poster and i
just never
you know um
[Music]
camp guy said we had a test done on our
daughter because she had a little bit of
heavy hair growing on her arms when she
was about six or seven
interesting
i remember seeing that was a little kid
on certain girls though yeah i think
it's just because hair is growing on
their arms and their arms are little so
it makes the hair look bigger
maybe that's what it is yeah because i
mean girls when they got a little older
they didn't have that well the thing
about it is like everybody like i have
hair on my arms too but it's like it's
blonde so you can't really see it
and it's not super thick so i never
worry about it
i mean i knew some girls that had kind
of thick hair on their arms and would
shave it off
which to me seems like a giant pain in
the ass but
i mean you know better to having hair on
your arms
yeah well yeah like i said if you had
like long thick black hair in your arms
yeah you probably would want to like
shave it but i'm like man shaving your
legs and all that other [ __ ] is like
[ __ ] enough of a pain in the ass
man i'm so [ __ ] sleepy man
would you want to end the show no okay
yeah like you want to end the show no i
was just saying i was just it just
occurred to me that i was like really
sleepy i woke up at
a little bit before five and i couldn't
go back to sleep
so i just i kind of laid there for a
while like trying to go back to sleep
and i was like [ __ ] it and then i had to
get up and
do my workout [ __ ] and then i had to
come in here and i started like
cleaning out the closet in there and
started packing stuff because i got my
boxes
is xanada in the in the cut in the uh
not that i've seen so far
fulbright said i tried to use xl for
doing a graph and was so lost i just
drew it
honestly
i can use
excel sort of
i can use microsoft word sort of
but
anytime i have to use any of the
microsoft office suite it's always an
exercise in frustration and i've had to
do it a few times because every now and
then i would get a client that was like
well we really absolutely need this
whatever it is like presentation or
whatever done in microsoft word at which
point like my anus always clenches i'm
like no
please don't make me and it's just kind
of like because i hate hate microsoft
word so much i think it's because i'm so
used to doing layouts in indesign and
illustrator which
just give you freedom you can put stuff
anywhere you can draw a text box over
here you can draw you and it's like it's
so easy and like so intuitive to me
so when you go and try to do [ __ ] in
microsoft word it's like okay i'm just
gonna put this text box here wait wait
why did it push everything to a second
page what the [ __ ] is happening it's
like everything is very it's like
designing a web page it's like you can
only put this [ __ ] like right here like
within this framework or otherwise gonna
[ __ ] up all this other [ __ ] over here
and it's like i can't stand that
so it's like i'm much
i'm much better with design programs
where i can just put [ __ ] wherever the
[ __ ] i want to put it and it doesn't
mess up anything else and microsoft word
is like the worst for that i had
seriously i every time i use microsoft
word to like do a layout i always have
to google something and it seems like
the easiest [ __ ] ever i'm like why does
it keep pushing all my [ __ ] to the
second page
like when i just draw a text box what
the [ __ ] is happening like you know what
i mean and obviously i'm not the only
person that has that problem because
as soon as i google it 40 million people
come up asking that same [ __ ]
question like why is this even happening
to me i don't understand
[Laughter]
i have no idea what you're talking about
i know you don't i have no idea what
you're talking about microsoft word is
uh at all the college i go to uses see i
would kill myself i try to do a
powerpoint what a disaster powerpoint
yeah it's the same it's the same thing
like i said they
everything goes into like like goes into
a grid and if you like kind of go a
little bit over into this little area of
this other area of the grid it's gonna
[ __ ] up everything that's over here like
it just and i can't
deal with that one time like a few times
i've had to do a powerpoint presentation
but i always cheat and i always make the
slides in photoshop and then import them
into powerpoint
you know what i mean like i'll make
everything in photoshop and then import
all of it into powerpoint as a
background and then put like one text
box in case they want to change it or
something like that and i'm just kind of
like [ __ ] it it's the end of the day i'm
like not even
i can't deal with it
it's too restrictive
the microsoft products
too restrictive
so i mean the only thing that i use
microsoft word for is just straight up
like if i'm doing a book layout not a
book layout but just writing a book
or writing a story like just i just use
it for word processing i don't use it to
do any kind of layout because
i know some people can do
amazing layouts in microsoft word i
don't have the patience um good on you
if you do i seriously do not it's too
complicated to figure out how to do the
simplest [ __ ] and it drives me [ __ ]
crazy
where the hell is tila anyway she hasn't
been on the show in about a week
she must have got swallowed up on
swallowed up
over there by a sinkhole yeah over there
in uh
over there in
san francisco must got swallowed up in
uh needles and human feces on this on
the sidewalk or something all those bums
got her bum zombies got her
guamo khan says i feel like word is so
cumbersome yeah that's a good word and
sensitive for visual media so making a
presentation on word sounds like a
nightmare it is
and honestly every time i have to do it
like i said i've had a few times
where a client specifically said can you
please do this in words so that you know
so we can alter it later like so we can
alter the text
and i'm always kind of like usually what
i'll try to do is i'll charge you like a
workaround and i'll be like okay well
how much of this can i actually do in
photoshop or illustrator and then just
export it like as a png file and then
import it into a like make a background
in word like make the page background
and then just slap a text box on top of
it so it's like because they don't need
to change any of the design elements
right so i'm just kind of like i'll just
make it a background on the page because
trying to do the [ __ ] that i want to do
it just doesn't look good
it's just i can't get it to work and
it's just and i don't have the patience
to get it to look the way i want to look
because
it should be easy and it's not
i mean
comparatively like illustrator and
photoshop or something like are just so
much easier because everything to me is
like really intuitive
like you know i want to put this here
you just put it there it's like not a
big [ __ ]
drama you know what i mean oh well you
have to go under this menu and you have
to do this or that and the other thing
and i'm like can i just [ __ ] put a
text box here
why can't i do that it's just like it
seems like it's
just it seems like it's difficult for
the sake of being difficult
[Laughter]
yeah philbert graham i agree with you
finally their professor the professor i
had said to just download pictures and
talk yeah i mean pretty much
like i said that every time i have to do
a powerpoint i just do the slides in
another program and import them into
powerpoint like as a picture like it's
the whole page and then just
there you go powerpoint presentation i'm
not making it in powerpoint because [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
victor hey i'm off today hey how are you
what's everybody drinking anyway
yeah it's wednesday night yeah
it's drinking night it's dry wealth
every night it's drinking it well it's
not really we didn't drink last night we
didn't drink drink every night we didn't
drink monday night we didn't we didn't
drink sunday night either no i had i had
a little bitty basically a week i had a
little bitty like this like this size
like a little
tumbler of apple juice and vodka on
sunday night but that's yeah i haven't
drunk something just eating drinking dr
pepper eating sunflower seeds
and we didn't go out saturday night
either
so like i said since we since we found
out we're moving we're like well we
better save some money
we didn't need to save up a bunch of
money well yeah because we thought oh
[ __ ] thousands of dollars yeah we were
thinking one we're either gonna have to
like scrape up and up for a down payment
on some [ __ ] or we're going to have to
like
rent somewhere and it's going to be
first and last and blah blah blah yeah i
even canceled a [ __ ] appointment with
the thriller to go look at the damn
[ __ ] colombian drug czar castle
i didn't tell them about the drugs that
was a cool house though yeah there was a
house we were looking at yeah where was
it
oh [ __ ] it was about honestly i think it
was farther yeah from here i think it
was about 40 minutes around 40 minutes
from here um and it was a spanish
castle
essentially yeah it was on like a big
piece it wasn't that expensive it was no
it said it needed a loving owner to
bring it back to its form i think it was
359 000.
um but it was no it was more than that
or three seventy nine eighty three
seventy nine three three seventy nine
that's what it was 379
built in the 1950s it says they don't
build them like this anymore it's just a
series of arches and levels and it was
like a spanish castle it was cool
looking very cool looking but thank you
victor very broke real kinda they had
like they had um
reclaimed a lot of wood and stuff from
like some like church they had torn
downs so there was these medieval like
wood looking like the um the stair rails
and stuff yeah and like the lighting
fixtures were all like handmade from
mexico and they were like all [ __ ]
gothic and medieval it was actually a
mexican house yeah i was looking at the
house going
if we have to buy a house i'm like this
is kind of far out there but i was like
this is super cool i could really do
something with that it was a mexican
castle i mean it was old it was an old
house 1950 something rather
and
it needed
for just from the photos i tell you it
needed new carpeting well yeah the
carpeting was like teal and it was it
was and it was like it was wrinkly so it
looked like it had gotten wet and they
had con they had decorated this thing
and some pimped out central american
colors it was like gold and teal
and orange
and red and gold and bronze
i mean red [ __ ] black red and bronze
and black are okay yeah it
i'm not i'm not a fan of gold though you
could definitely tell that this was like
uh
somebody's 1970s [ __ ] pimp castle the
front doors it was double front doors
and they were hand carved mahogany yeah
it was super cool looking cool i mean i
did look at it and i was kind of like
man if we had to buy a house like i said
it's kind of far away yeah but i was
kind of like man that [ __ ] is cool
it's cool looking all the rooms were
pretty square though um it but it had
big rims they were big but they were all
kind of rectangular
they weren't modern nothing was modern
about this it had that's okay it had a
hallway running down and then it would
look then you could look over the ledge
down to the lower floors it had decks on
the outside the [ __ ]
roofs and the ceilings were like on a
[ __ ] chapel
um
big [ __ ]
doors
it had a thing where kyle it was it was
time well all the the all the lower
floor was tile it was only the upstairs
that had that ugly like oh carter blonde
would own it was kind of rad i have to
say like because i'm not it needed work
though it did it needed the carpet torn
out um it needed to be repainted
well yeah obviously it uh it needed some
updating and the thing that i was
worried about was
what was the central air like
um stone houses like that it's a cot it
was a concrete house and stone
they tend to stay pretty cool
so energy bills probably wouldn't have
been that bad it's just that i have a
feeling that [ __ ] that [ __ ] was a
[ __ ] pain in the ass for
for heating and cooling and uh electric
power it's 1950s yeah
which means it probably wasn't built
with central air because a lot of houses
weren't in the 50s added probably
because even the new houses i don't know
about ones that expensive but i mean my
grandmother's house in uh daytona was
built in 1958
and they didn't build them with central
air in fact it didn't have any air
conditioning later on she got a window
unit you could park your car you could
come you could come into the driveway
and
the house the bottom floor of the house
was a series of arches that went all the
way around it it was like this massive
arches and you could drive into those
arches into a carport that could
probably fit about
six to eight cars
but and it was also the porch though i
didn't see a garage yeah i don't think
it wasn't really a modern it wasn't a
modern house
it didn't look like it had a garage it
looked like there was like a carport and
then there was like a porch but if you
wanted to you could like pull all the
way because the porch was like really
really wide and big
and
the second floor top the second floor
was a big sun deck and the second floor
was smaller than the [ __ ] bottom
floor
so you had depth yeah it was like it was
like square like this like this is where
the main [ __ ] was like the kitchen and
like most of the bedrooms and then on
the bottom floor it had like this long
it looked like a long haul with like an
office or something at the end that's
what it looked like to me
um louie would love that [ __ ] louie this
[ __ ] i thought it was cool looking i
mean the only thing that like i said you
know we didn't end up we did actually
make an appointment to go see it but
then when the landlords came over and
said no we just want to swap houses here
you can have this yeah i was like that's
so much easier um yeah i'm like okay
well that would be better because that
house we would have had to buy it you
had to buy it and um and then and then
refurbish and then refurnish it and like
and you know take out all that horrible
carpet upstairs because that carpet was
like [ __ ] up yeah um it looked like it
was in okay shape otherwise i think i
don't think that house had changed hands
very many times probably not but like i
said you know the only thing that was
somebody's family yeah the only thing
that gave me pause was that one it was
much farther away than we were wanting
it was like 40 minutes from here yeah
that was a fazenda man um and two
because it was old years old so i was
like well that might be like some
maintenance problems um
normally the structure would have been
sound though probably a stone this [ __ ]
like that can stand for hundreds of
years it's all the wiring
that's what it means
that's what i'm talking about it's more
that i don't think the house is going to
blow away because obviously it's still
standing there yeah but it's more like
you know do we need to update the pipes
like the plumbing do we need to update
the ac does it have ac like what about
the wiring is the wiring all [ __ ] up
you know what i mean it's you know i i
had a house i owned a house for a while
in daytona that was built in 1964.
and it wasn't bad
but
you had to constantly [ __ ] watch it
was just a concrete block house but you
had to constantly watch it all the time
and it's like termites and you know the
electricity wasn't up to snuff you had
to like i had to have some [ __ ] rewired
and all this other kind of stuff so it's
kind of like
you know it's just something you have to
take into consideration even though in
general
i don't know because i don't like
um
i don't like a lot of modern
architecture i don't really like a lot
of the sleek
uh
just nothing
you know i don't like [ __ ] that looks
like a boxer i really like
baroque gothic looking [ __ ] i like old
[ __ ] but i don't want it to actually be
old necessarily because it's too much of
a pain
i just wanted to look old victor victor
vince garcia's in there that that's one
of our [ __ ] um mexican american
[ __ ] fans and i'll tell you what all
my mexicans even [ __ ] even khan all my
mexicans all my mexicans
all my mexicans they would have loved
this house this [ __ ] house like i
said i thought it was super cool one of
my favorite things like if it's like a
mexican castle in florida one of my
favorite things well okay my two
favorite things
were
the railing around the staircase which
which they said that they had gotten
from a church that had been torn down so
it was like this old like very gothic
looking like very catholic looking
church thing like it looked like old
monastery
and the lighting fixtures yeah the
lighting fixtures were just
yeah
yeah wrought iron looking [ __ ] beautiful
with like some stained glass oh they
were gorgeous and they uh
they were going out of their way to say
that all this wood was from mexico
yeah
well the lighting fixtures were too they
were hand-made from mexico and the front
doors were also
came out of mexican churches
cathedrals and [ __ ] cool it was super
cool looking but it was best [ __ ] was
forgot this [ __ ] it was i would have got
the [ __ ] out of that actually you could
have [ __ ] um dia de los muertos that
the hell out of that [ __ ] which
i prefer
mexican mexican skulls and day of the
dead [ __ ] would have looked like i had
painted all those walls red and like put
all kind of [ __ ] did all that [ __ ]
mexican that have been david that have
been there awesome look really cool yeah
you have a mexican gothic house that's
what i was thinking when i was like
looking at it yeah i was thinking oh
it's not practical i could do all kinds
of [ __ ] well yeah if i had unlimited
money yeah it's just that um i could
just got the [ __ ] out of that house
because you wouldn't even have to do
that much with it and honestly i had 30
000 [ __ ] saved up then that would
have been an easy thing but yeah if i
had that extra 30 grand we could have
found a better mexican castle probably
down there
the only thing the even the house was so
cool looking
that you know like all the um the doors
and trim and everything were all wood
and they were like natural wood and
normally i don't like that because i
don't like brown i don't even like the
look of natural wood really i you know
if you're gonna have like wood flooring
or something like that i would prefer
like cherry or like ebony or something
like that i don't like that blonde
i don't like brown okay i just don't
like brown i don't like anything brown
so but this house all of the doors and
trim were mahogany where wood
and i liked it so much that i was like
you know what i wouldn't even paint that
because it's too pretty and it would be
a shame to paint it even though normally
i would paint it because i hate brown
juice you're saying did it have a
dedicated tortilla making nook
it probably did
maybe it did and then philbert's saying
uh all that wood would have from from
the mexican churches would have kept the
[ __ ] evil spirits
yeah somebody else or attracted them i'm
not really sure how does that work then
somebody else is talking saying that
mexico had more catholics than like the
vatican and europe and [ __ ] i've heard
that yeah well you have to understand
how
how the mesoamerican
religion how it
fell
under cortez and the and the conquista
and all that
um then the dominican friars and [ __ ]
that were in charge
of the conversion of the of the mexican
people and how that [ __ ] happened
european history and a lot of [ __ ]
marxists interpretation of the [ __ ]
whole thing is very inaccurate
cortez did not
overthrow
the mexican
city of [ __ ]
a [ __ ] um
of the aztecs
really what he did is he he led a
rebellion of all the other mesoamerican
cities against them
because the aztecs were despotic and
they were making all the other
mesoamericans and other indians and the
other cities around it paid the blood
debt of the mexicans to the gods
so it wasn't just some spaniards that
did this they led the attack they
inspired it they they inspired the
revolt but it was the other indians that
did most of the fighting and all the
dying
so they overthrew
the the uh you know the aztec capital
city
and they didn't have to worship the
aztec gods anymore
well the catholics and the dominican
friars found out they did kind of an
analysis of mesoamerican culture and its
religions
and the mesoamerican religion was real
close to catholicism
every
indian god there was a catholic saint or
a catholic concept
that was equivalent to that
so really the mexicans are still
worshiping the same religion as they
always did it just has a veneer of
catholicism over it it's a different
they're reinterpreting
the indian religion as catholicism
that's like day the dead you know their
version of halloween and a lot of the
stuff that mexicans do like you know
santa muerte and everything
it looks catholic on the surface but
it's meso-american
actually in its heart just like the
people they're a mixture you know
and uh that's uniquely mexican
so their interpret their religion is
their version of catholicism is uniquely
mexican it's it's their own
it just appears to be european
that's my take on it
um and uh khan agrees with me uh jair
who he lives right there in tijuana
that it's
mexican catholicism is just a
reinterpretation of the same religion
that they had before the spaniards came
that's all they just got rid of certain
practices like child sacrifice
and human sacrifice at least at the
mainstream you still have some of the
narcos still do it
you know
in a way some of the some of the [ __ ]
that they're doing is very similar to
human sacrifice
the mesoamerican religion if you look at
how they did things you know
bloodletting
cutting fingertips off capturing people
in ritualized combat to sacrifice them
to pay the blood debt to keep the
[ __ ] cycle of the sun running going
and everything all that [ __ ] made
perfect sense if you understood the
system that they were living under it
wasn't insane
they were crazy [ __ ] macho as hell
but it did make sense when you
understood the stories that they
believed in it it's a very interesting
culture
and strangely enough
people who are not mexican are more
interested in it than a lot of mexicans
are a lot of mexicans aren't really
interested in that
um a lot of the experts in it
are uh american or or european they'll
go there to [ __ ] study all this stuff
and they can speak nahaltel you know the
the
and and learn that you know learned the
aztec
uh language
and um
try to analyze it on a mythological
level of what it is that they're talking
about you know the the underworld
shaboba
[ __ ] all these cenotes and
what that all meant think of [ __ ] how
hardcore that was
the aztec version of hell was shaboba
it was the underworld
and for them it really existed it was
all this underground cave network
back before it got flooded you could go
down in there
so
dudes were going into hell
with [ __ ]
to to lay bodies
honored bodies of the dead down in there
before it all flooded they found [ __ ]
ex divers have found guys
dead whole you know groups of three or
four of them up against the wall
with torches and [ __ ]
that's before the water got in there
they were walking around they were miles
and miles hundreds of miles they were
miles away from any entrance
they were in there exploring and laying
people to rest
the honored dead and you know you lose
your your torch goes out there man
you're [ __ ] you're in total darkness
there's no way out
i don't know if you just wait around die
of thirst or if they brought poison
they must have known it was a dangerous
trip i'm thinking that they probably
brought poison
or they cut their wrists if they
if their if their light ever went out
because you weren't gonna make it out
no way
and i wouldn't wait wait around for
thirst to take me
but imagine they slipped their wrists or
they took poison if their lamps went out
but they found them in there like
explorers on the moon that was the
equivalent of going to the [ __ ] moon
walking down into the underworld
imagine man
yeah imagine how [ __ ] brave you had
to be to do that
you believe you're walking into hell
literally you know that's my hardcore
[ __ ]
somebody asked us to post a picture of
that please did you find it um yeah i
found the address so you could probably
find it on here yeah let me see hold on
uh it's
what
give me the address and i'll show it to
him one six one two zero
tyring ham hey spell t y uh
florida right yeah that's it
come and see what pictures come up
i found it on zillow all right
but yeah this was this was the house we
were we were gonna go look at
yeah that's it
like a lot of the where the arches are
that's like a porch
and then
back behind it is like a hall in an
office type of situation that's the
mexican castle it can't get it to focus
there it goes
yeah show like that staircase like on
the inside because i love that reclaimed
i love that reclaimed wood it's just
like really really pretty
there it is and like i said it was a big
big piece of property too and i think
that
it and i think that it gave you like um
lake access there was like a lake across
the road with a dock and that was part
of your property too even though it was
across the street
i'm pretty sure that's the same picture
it's near this lake
yeah and you had like you had a little
bit on the lake too like a little dock
like that was included
in the property but it was like across
the street
yeah it looked like that
yeah it was really cool looking yeah
3.95 three it was
which isn't bad it was four bedrooms and
three baths
it was cool like i said it was cool
looking that's the porch that's the car
see and like look at the front doors
i love it
and like i said i'm not a big fan of
like wood but
yeah look at that [ __ ]
this is the inside
yeah look at that i guess that's when
you open the front door i'd imagine
yeah because that looks like the front
door
yeah and that's like the other side see
it's got that horrible like teal carpet
which looked really old but
that wouldn't be a big look it looks
like it looks like they're shining yeah
i would change that carpeting
to something darker i mean we're not
having this now this is this isn't the
house we're going to but that's
available people if you guys want to buy
but this is the house that was that we
were going to go look at yeah before we
knew that the landlords were just
essentially giving us another house
yeah but see i was like oh i could got
the [ __ ] out of that
where's the where's the one with like
the staircase that had the what are you
doing pokey i hear you sneezing hallways
yeah look at those lighting fixtures
see i like [ __ ] like that
look how beautiful i don't like all this
modern [ __ ] like modern looking [ __ ]
so if you want your mexican people to
see a nice tile there it is
and like i said it's not that expensive
for like how nice it is it needs some
work yeah but it needs new carpeting it
needs to be painted in certain areas
i don't think it's as big as you think
it is well it might not be but it's like
it's still nice looking though the price
is right the location's great
it's old school yeah
i even kind of like that tiffany lamp up
there well that sort of stained glassy
looking thing even though it kind of
looks like pizza at circa 1985.
yeah 85 looking but that's okay
it was built to last yeah
see i like look at that see look at the
look at that see i love that i love that
i mean the stairs are my favorite part
that's the family room i think
bless you pokey yeah see look how cool
that is doesn't it it looks like ricardo
monteblanc yeah that's what i mean
welcome
was gonna put some fine corinthian
leather in there that's the laundry room
what are you doing pokey
i hear back there sneezing
she snuffles at the carpet and then
sneezes that's the laundry room
or the garage or i don't know what that
is
no the lawn do you already showed the
light it showed the uh it was actually
where the
utility room it's where the uh dryer the
water heater those are the bedrooms the
bedrooms are not very big i don't think
yeah see the stairs and stuff were like
my favorite part of it
carpet is badly buckled see yeah well
like i said that carpet is old
but it wouldn't be that big a deal to
like tear that up and then honestly you
can like snap in your own [ __ ]
flooring nowadays yes look at the lady
picture i love it i love it
look how [ __ ] gas that is
this is the backyard
yeah
so yeah super super nice
yeah like i said so yeah they're selling
that for
395 000.
like i said it's old and it needs some
it needs some work but
that was we were gonna go see it but
like i said then there then the um
landlords came over in the morning and
said no you can have this house and we
were like oh okay but you can see the uh
it's got 42 pictures of it you can see
it yeah
it's not that big i don't know 1620
tiring ham yeah use the other ones
around it are bigger you can see it's
that looks like south or central america
there all those buildings look like it
yeah
well you know like i said
in some ways it's cool having a big
house but the bigger the house is it's
like the more you got to clean yeah
because i can't afford to hire maid
[ __ ] i was telling you guys i said
look parts of florida are basically
central america i meant it
yeah
including the architecture
there is a lot of spanish architecture
around here yeah
and that's you know everybody wants
everything to look like a
villa in madrid yeah or something
and i think i feel like italian
architecture too everybody wants [ __ ] to
look like it's on the riviera
you know there's a lot of that too bless
you you all right you got allergies oh
she look what she brought what'd you
bring she brought this oh just the minty
come here
i have all kind of new minties i think
she's asking me to let her out
well you i'm going to see
you oh every time you like hold stuff up
to the camera it like [ __ ] the lighting
all up look
now then it goes all pale almost like
the camera is kind of like
mr roboto says so you are moving yes we
are yeah it'll be a couple months though
um do not move into that house i mean as
cool as that house that was the house
that we were looking at
before
we found out that the landlords
like were wanted to swap houses with us
so they're giving us a bigger one for
the same
rent
it's two-story
so
we're gonna go friday and get the keys
and then move in over the next two
months
but we'll keep streaming from here
for as long as we can bless you goodness
you all right pool do you have a cold
i just hear her back there sneezing and
poor little babies you okay you okay
yeah she's playing with the busy no
maybe that's what it is she's kind of
like i just i buy those minties by the
[ __ ]
case because both her and beijing love
those [ __ ] little mint toys you get them
for chewy for like two dollars or
something
and it's just like she picks them up in
one paw
and just rubs them all over her face oh
god oh it's like it's the best thing
ever beijing does that to you
man little beijing last night she was i
don't know why i could just it was early
it wasn't even the middle of the night
it was only like seven o'clock and i
could i all i heard was her from the
living room just going
like that little sad
cry that she makes and then when i went
out there was like all these stuffed
animals like this she's been like
carrying the stuffed animals all around
the house people seem to like that house
yeah it's cool looking right i thought
it was like super cool looking
i mean the one we're going to
i can't remember what the um
what's that dress he said it does have a
tortilla nook
i don't know what it looks like man yeah
we don't know what a turkey is
we don't know what a tortilla duck looks
like gotta have a super chat party the
first stream from the new house we
should
we um
yeah because the nice thing about it is
because because we can move in slowly
over two months
and i'm not gonna move the streaming
stuff until like the last possible
minute so
i'm gonna be able to like set up the
office studio over there exactly the way
i want it
before we start streaming hopefully so
hopefully there won't be too much
disruption i mean
if we have to like maybe skip a couple
live stream shows i don't know if we
will we might not have to
but
because like i said we're just gonna
keep i already packed up like a couple
boxes
and we're just gonna take stuff over
there
like a little bit at a time
and so it'll be it'll be
it'll be good i'm looking at aerial
photos of that house it's not very big
well like i said that's a another one
the one that we're going to is bigger
than that it didn't i don't even know
did it say how many square feet i didn't
look if it does
on zillow it would always say how many
square feet it was
i didn't look either
i'm not really all that bothered about
that but like i said it would have been
cool though
yeah it's a cool looking house i would
have put like a reddish brown carpet
through that whole thing and changed it
to a more somber
darker tone i would have just tiled the
whole [ __ ] thing tile or like that's
in the snap wood a lot of money
i don't you know what i'm doing myself
well yeah doing the snap vinyl um my
brother did that in his house and he
said it was super easy
like nowadays they have all that like
snap together vinyl flooring that looks
like wood yeah you know what i mean can
it stand up or though or is it like yeah
yeah okay yeah he did that in his house
and he said he was ready linoleum would
[ __ ] buckle and warp no they have
like they have way better [ __ ] nowadays
that's like that's some old school [ __ ]
yeah my brother did um it's vinyl but it
looks like wood yeah and it does you
don't need glue you don't need anything
you just it just all snaps together and
it's like super tight and it just yeah
you know and it looks like way better
uh what does pookie and beijing think
about the new house they haven't been
yet dude what we're gonna do is
make like slowly introduce them
so you wanna watch ty
why you were you grumbling she's like
i think she's like put my clothes on so
i can go outside and just put her
clothes on
um
what we're gonna do is we're gonna take
some of their like favorite toys over
there and then like maybe take them over
there in their little carriers and let
them run around and then i think the
last thing we're gonna take is their cat
tree because
pookie sleeps in that cat tree like
every day so i didn't so i wouldn't want
to take it away like early and she'd be
like where's my [ __ ] cat tree you
know i want to sleep in my little
apartment or my bowl or whatever and
it's not there but
um we're gonna take like some of their
other things like some of their toys
just so when they go in the house like
they'll there'll be stuff there that
smells like them
you know what i mean
uh so they won't be like weirded out
like where the [ __ ] am i type of
situation
yeah bees now says my cat freaked out
for about three or four days when i
first moved here she wouldn't eat her
drink see i'm kind of worried but
what false alarm
she always does
she wanted to call her yeah put the
collar on let's go let's go and she goes
the door and she's like nah just kidding
[Laughter]
she just wants to see if you'll do more
attention that's what it is well yeah
she just wants daddy to play with her
oh baby girl come up on the show come be
on the show on the show hey there's
pookie be honest yeah hi tweety we're
talking about moving some of your little
toys like maybe your little unicorn
friend or your little gnomes
we can take them to the new house
she loves those little gnomes in that
unicorn we have them like in a little
pile in the closet and she just goes in
there and like
says hi to them like every morning she
runs in there and she just kind of like
noses
sometimes i'll sit down on the closet
floor and i'll take her little unicorn
it's this crazy little i think we just
got it at publix or something
it's this little
pink
unicorn us on my tablet oh my god look
it's it's tiny mommy and daddy yeah
she's like this is weirding me out
yeah
it's this tiny pink unicorn with little
shiny silver
uh hooves
and it has like feathers sticking out of
the back of it for some reason and like
a little silver thing and we just
thought it was like super cute and fun
super chat pookie
oh boy
you just got a super chat pokey thank
you david yeah
she looks gray on my she is great she is
gray yeah she is gray
yeah
what are you looking at me like that for
cheeseburger oh baby girl
you're the funniest guy yeah she's
[ __ ] hilarious but yeah she has this
that little unicorn and like sometimes
i'll i'll like
walk the little unicorn up to her and
like talk to and she's just like oh my
god i love you unicorn and then i'm like
look i'm gonna ride on your back and i
put the unicorn on her back and she's
just like what the [ __ ]
she's looking at that she's looking at
this super chat girl up a little bit
she's looking at yeah well she likes
daddy's um
it's like because he like he has it on
like a lot of times like at night like
he's a better yeah headphones on and he
has it on the nightstand and she will
jump up on the bed she'll jump up on my
chest and be like hi mama hi and i'm
just like hi sweetie and then she goes
over to like his side and i see her go
over like next to him and like watch a
tab he's looking at the tablet and she's
looking she's standing there looking at
the tablet every now and then she'll
kind of touch it yeah she'll touch the
tablet she can see human faces
on the tablet talking she's those little
people she sees images but she's mostly
interested in the tablet not the
television it's weird
yeah she didn't really seem to give a
[ __ ] about the tv
um
even sometimes like we'll be watching a
movie and if there's a cat in the movie
i'm always like look pookie a kitty and
she's just like don't care yeah um the
only time she cares about it is if we're
watching the tv and not her and then
she'll jump up on the table in front of
the tv
so we'll be looking at her instead of at
the tv and she'll lay down in front of
the lay down so you can see her little
ears like in front it's like mystery
science theater except kitty mode yeah
so i'm just kind of like you want to be
in the movie kitty you want to be in the
book because she just like sits there
it's like she's like why are you guys
looking looking at this stupid thing why
don't you just look at how cute i am
that's kind of what her deal is
look at her look at her
oh my god pokey you're so cute
she has no idea what's going on dg
maniac said i thought for the life of me
she was black no she's gray she's gray
she's always been gray she has very very
subtle striping as well although you
can't really see it unless you're
looking at her like really close
but
cats are gonna love the big house that's
what we keep telling her
it's like annette has stairs i don't
think you've ever experienced a house
with stairs before
because she's never been anywhere except
here yeah
this has been her only house blow her
mind she's gonna be like what the [ __ ]
is going on she's been to the vet that's
it yeah that's the only place she's been
right yeah she's been to the vet a few
times and that's it had her in the kitty
carrier holding her up
just facing the [ __ ] front windscreen
of the [ __ ] so she could watch the
cars she was just looking outside going
yeah man she mailed the whole time she
wasn't like she wasn't crying she wasn't
but she just um she because i would she
was tripping well she didn't like being
because i was holding her in my lap and
she didn't like being in my lap and i
was like you want to watch you want to
see outside pookie and i was like and so
i held her up so she could see out the
window and she was just like what the
[ __ ] and she just i thought she was in
the tardis
i thought you were in the tardis
what the [ __ ] is happening all the space
time is [ __ ] distorted she's like
everything's moving i don't get it yeah
do you remember when we took her to this
artist
we took her to the vet that one time
and i think they gave her
well then they gave her like her little
shots or whatever and she did not like
that and i thought it was so funny that
she either bit or clawed not the person
giving the shot but you yeah yeah she
blamed me she blamed you even though you
were across from she was just like ah
yeah you brought me here nurses went up
to her and laid on her to hold her down
and they gave her a shot and then they
let go and then she stood up she was on
the little the little operating table
thing she stood up and looked at them
and then turned around and looked at me
and went ah and bit me yeah [ __ ]
and then they laugh
she's like yeah because i didn't stop
him she yeah she's like why don't you
protect me daddy yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] the [ __ ] she just laughed
she blamed you yeah
we're like yeah without figures that
seems like something
something she would do
esther says new toys and new cat tree
for pookie and beijing we might actually
get a new cat tree at some point
although pookie does really like that
one
beijing we actually got that tree before
we had pookie so that was beijing's tree
for a while yeah but then when pookie
came she was like for a while they kind
of like shared it sort of yeah they
fight over even though it was like
grudging yeah like beijing would be up
at the top and then pookie would come to
the bottom and she would look up there
and then beijing is like don't you think
about it you little brat and that was
that expensive how much was that thing
i think it was maybe 100 100 120
something like that yeah it was a long
time ago it might be time to get another
one um but like i said pookie really
likes that one but beijing won't use it
anymore the house is big enough because
it's got pookie cooties the that house
is big enough to have several of them
anyway
we should probably have one upstairs and
downstairs now that i'm thinking about
it right we should probably also get
more litter boxes like for upstairs and
downstairs
because like i said we've never we've
never lived in a house with them with
with upstairs and downstairs before i
think no i think
one litter box is enough they know where
it is as long as they know where it is
they'll go to it they don't need to
they asked if the house has an attic or
a basement well hardly anything has a
basement in florida no basements in
florida um because it's it would just
flood it
it should have attic space most of these
most of the modern houses i mean our
house here has attic space over the
garage it's not massive no we have two
uh
over the laundry room too just to never
use it oh i didn't even know that there
was yeah there's one attic space in
there yeah
in the garage i never noticed thing you
go back and there's some pickles that's
where all the christmas stuff should
come down they're not unfold you can go
up there there's another room in there
it's just that there's no real floor i
had to lay out a bunch of
wood yeah it's just like and then step
stick there and there's also you know
the ceiling's got nails going through
it's hot as [ __ ] up there
you
besides the christmas decorations most
of that [ __ ] can probably go
yeah i mean i need to go through it
because i think some of it's mine
you've got tapes up there your old tape
collections
but yeah well that's another thing why i
want to pull all that down one day and
like look through it because a lot of
like i said a lot of stuff i just don't
want to take it yeah i mean to be honest
because
i have so much stuff like in this house
and it's been in here for years and i
haven't looked at it so i feel like well
i might as well just like throw it out
or give it away because
if i didn't look at it for the last five
or six years i'm not going to look at it
for the next five years if you don't
[ __ ] with it for 10 years then you don't
[ __ ] with it pretty much unless it's
family photos or something yeah unless
it's something you really can't replace
you know what i mean
it's that kind of thing
isn't the safest place in a hurricane a
basement
um
i guess technically it would be but like
i said it's just a lot of houses here
don't have them and i think it's able to
yeah it's it's because of the flooding
um you can't
honestly you dig down like two or three
feet in your backyard and there's water
like in some places
so it's a swamp yeah it's florida's
essentially a swamp so you can't really
have a basement and honestly i was
thinking my grandfather's house which
has since been torn down which was torn
down many years ago which was built in
maybe the 1920s
it had a basement but most of the
basement was above ground you know what
i mean like half of it was kind of under
but then half of it was kind of over
and then the house was just kind of
raised you know what i'm saying
so even a house that does have a
basement it's not entirely underground
just because
like i said it would flood
immediately
pretty much anywhere in florida because
everywhere is at sea level
and
you know
even like i said even around here you
have to watch too like when you're um
buying a house
and i think even zillow will say like
what the flood zone thing is because in
florida it's pretty much all a flood
zone um because like i said it's pretty
much all at sea level
but
it's better to have property that's a
little bit
raised just in case
because there's one house not too far
from here i think i brought this up
before that's like
you pass like the backyard of it like on
the trail like that i walk on
every time it rains heavily their entire
backyard floods
and it's just it basically turns into
like a pond and then oh you know all the
birds and [ __ ] are super excited you see
like ducks swimming in it and like
[ __ ] cranes and all this stuff
they're like woohoo new pond but uh you
know i'm sure that's like and it takes a
really really long time to like dry back
up because it's so [ __ ] humid here
so i'm sure that's not exciting for them
that like every time it storms there's
like well
backyard's a [ __ ]
pond again there we go
and they can't let their dogs out that's
just kinda
yeah it's just it's just too
it's too wet
you just can't like i said the basements
would just flood
brad jones are you all moving yes we are
like i said i fee i feel like when when
new people come because we i think we
made the announcement on sunday but i
know that not everybody watches the
sunday shows because that's just movie
review yeah we're um
we're going to we're essentially
swapping houses with our landlord
because the landlords which who are a
couple
um the guy is getting too old they live
in a house now that's two-story and the
guy is getting too old to walk up and
down stairs so they're like well we
wanted to move into this house the house
we live in um they're like but for the
same price we will give you this other
property that we own and you can rent it
for the same price as you're renting now
even though it's like much bigger and
it's two stories so we're moving to a
much bigger house it's about 10 15
minutes from here
and um for the same rent so we're very
excited about it but we have two months
to move and i have off i have an option
to buy and we yeah which
i could buy it i probably should he
tried to sell me this one when i moved
in here and gave me another opportunity
to buy it about two years in
he wanted too much
yeah well he was probably right because
he knew this location was going to blow
up
yeah although the thing about it though
is that we've been here for enough time
that had enough equity he should have
given me some of that back off of his
[ __ ] sale price but yeah it is he's
trying to make money he's he's a real
estate mogul motherfucker's got 13 or 14
of these damn things yeah he's got and
he's got a younger son who's
a lawyer who's also a real estate agent
who's in charge of all this [ __ ] hold on
you know what that lighting looks
terrible didn't it well yeah that's
after you held up all the footage it
like readjusted and then yeah it just
it's nicer like that yeah
and then
um so i understand why he did it he
knows what he's doing i mean you know
you you don't become a rich man by being
a [ __ ] idiot
you know you do it by being hard
but i'm thinking about maybe
i should investigate buying that
because if i were in there for 10 years
and i'd have most of the [ __ ] paid
off anyway
on a 15 year yeah you could look at i
mean ask a 15-year loan we'll say about
the va because you have i mean veterans
have you get loan assistance
and
also first-time buyers because you've
never bought a house before it's because
i i have so i can't get that um but
you've never bought one so you could
probably get that first-time homebuyer's
assistance also like a priority they do
give you breaks like lower interest
rates [ __ ] like that depending on how
solid the federal government is we'll
see and the us dollar
[Laughter]
anything could happen with these
[ __ ] now well anything could
happen anywhere i'll tell you it's like
don't worry about it tell you what if
you got to live somewhere if you're
paying on it and those [ __ ] go south
you got possession possession is nine
tenths of the law you it ended up being
your house it's not your fault that
those [ __ ] folded well that's
what i'm saying so don't worry about it
yeah it's like better than it's like you
know what do you want to live out out on
a [ __ ] bench or some [ __ ] like that
because well no
no because the the
in that way that the landlord would be
would would have been the [ __ ]
government or a bank if they don't exist
anymore then that means it's yours yeah
if it's our landlord then it's not the
same
it means it would be his
you know yeah it makes more sense maybe
i should uh
if we get in there and if it's good then
i arrange to buy it
yeah i mean we'll see how it goes um i
mean
it seems cool i mean we've been
you know we drove there we drove around
where the house was 10 years went by
fast here to see where everything was
like make sure there was a grocery store
within you know distance 10 years went
by fast here it did and i was paying
enough a monthly that it would that
would have covered a 15-year mortgage
cost and i'd have been home i'd be out
of [ __ ] owned a majority of it you
could sell it and make profit
yeah yeah another five years we'd have
probably had it like half people had
more than half on a 15-year mortgage
we'd have to have
half we have more than half paid off
costs would have been the same
yeah
i think the problem a lot of years ago
we would have been able to flip it i
mean the problem the thing that's hard
about home buying is that a lot of times
you have to have
a certain percentage down payment
now
if
that's the thing it's i kind of feel
like maybe nowadays i remember back when
i was buying a house
um
i could sell motorcycles and come up
with 20 000.
when i was uh buying a house
yeah back in um 2000 whenever the hell
it was 2002 2003 i can't remember when i
was buying a house generally the
standard was
they liked the mortgage companies liked
you to put 20 down which is a lot of
money depending on how much the house
was
uh because i was a first-time homebuyer
i was able to go through was it fannie
mae or freddie mac or whatever and i
just i think i ended up just putting
down i think i just put down five
percent maybe
but see the more you put down for a down
payment the less you have to pay
every month you know what i mean the
like the lower your monthly payment is
but not a lot of people can come up with
20 especially if you're buying a 400 000
house
um 20 of 400 thousand dollars is a lot
so mr robato is asking so we have a raft
in case of flooding it doesn't flood
here not here we're we're a little bit
raised up yeah um now i'm not saying if
there was like a real bad hurricane
it would flood but normally if there's a
hurricane it'll flood on the coasts yeah
um you know not too bad no i might flood
in a bowl or a depression that's what
i'm saying like those people's backyard
like up on the path like turns into a
pond every time it rains yeah but it's
like six inches deep
yeah but it stays there for a long time
and then it starts to smell yeah it's
big but it's only like
then it starts to smell and like all the
animals come around they get all yeah
they got the damn [ __ ] pelicans and
[ __ ] walking through and ducks ducks
living in frogs yeah i gotta watch
because every time there's a bad storm
and if i when i walk the next morning
when it's all flooded a lot of times
like little baby frogs will be like
jumping from that pond to the pond
across the path so there would be like
just millions of little baby frogs going
don't don't drink like across the path
and you have to like be careful what's
funny when you think of when you think
of swamp you think a lot of people will
think of some kind of african jungle or
something or the rain forest out in
brazil
that's not what it looks like it looks
like a coniferous forest it's pie trees
it's just that it's flat
yeah and um
it can flood in certain areas
there's no drainage and there's a lot of
rain because we're the elevation is
pretty low
yeah like i said we're generally like we
average at sea level yeah quite average
there are some places that are a little
bit hilly but it's not we don't have any
mountains or hills or much of anything
like that in an everglade area it's
under water basically most of it's
underwater it's underwater by a couple
of inches there's another big old long
grass tall grass
and what they call a mandrake trees no
what's that kind of tree what's that
tree that they have with all the little
[ __ ] uh knees sticking up out of the
way yeah
did [ __ ] call those things yeah i
think it is mangrove
mangroves
that's everywhere
the thing is is that when you see that
[ __ ] you're gonna see that [ __ ] on
television you're not gonna see it in
person because there's no roads that
really lead there's one road that goes
through the everglades the alligator
alley yeah that's about it you know what
i mean it's not accessible to the public
you'd have to [ __ ] be being a swamp
boat
which you'll see swamp boats here
what was it about it yes
yeah but we had mississippi called swamp
yeah swambo airboat whatever airfoil
and it's a
guys build them i don't even think you
can buy them i just think they build
them
you can buy them but well essentially it
looks like a boat with like a big ass
fan on the back is what is what it looks
like it's a flat bottom boat with a
raised [ __ ] engine any kind of motor
you can find and you put a [ __ ]
propeller on the back of it from an
airplane and it's a pusher prop and then
you put a big guard around it so you
don't get sucked into the [ __ ]
blade because that would be bad yeah
and you don't have anything in the water
you can be into you could be in total
[ __ ] moss or just undergrowth if
they're you don't even need water they
will blow themselves across [ __ ]
solid ground
a lot of people think it's got to be in
the water it doesn't
well because the thing about the
everglades is that you know it's mostly
water but there is like land in there
yeah so go over the land so they just
need something that'll go over both
things it can be in an inch of water
it'll go fast inch of water with a whole
bunch of [ __ ] grass and [ __ ]
no problem
and then if there's if there's a finger
of [ __ ] sand or sand bar or something
sticking out doesn't matter it goes
right over it you could run it up on the
land pro you know i don't know how for
how long it'd probably get hot on the
bottom that probably your biggest limit
yeah depending on on you know if it was
sad it'd probably get hot
i don't know you had to look you have to
look but i've seen him go over over
ground
there was no reason to like
um i saw somebody load one up into the
trailer that way
they were like in a you know what i mean
like yeah the trailers you put the boat
on he just
ran up into the trailer yeah with the
thing there wasn't any pulling it in
just
the pusher prop had enough power to get
it in there
you just don't want to overshoot it
you're sailing over the front [ __ ]
cab of the truck
hold my beer
i had them in louisiana
but in mississippi we didn't have them
there wasn't a need for them
yeah you see them around here so like i
said it's more common in the everglades
because that's all swamps
and there's only one road
as far as i know there's only one road
that goes through the everglades from
all like all the way across because the
everglades is all the way across
southern florida like pretty much yeah
other than like right near the coast
it's all across like the central part of
the state
kind of like ocala national forest like
i said it takes up like a huge
amount of the center center part of the
state and there's like nothing out there
it's just all woods
it's just it's weird too that like what
you're doing
what are you doing pokey pulling
why are you pulling she's stretching i'm
switching on the chair
what's that i think she's telling me
about that okay but this is the second
time so we'll see
was a dry rut
[Laughter]
yeah she just wanted to see if you'd get
up and do it
she has a weird thing where she does
this pretty much every night and he
keeps falling for it
um
she gets all excited she starts like
grumbling and grumbling she's like
like she wants to go outside and she
gets all like her little tail wags and
stuff and so i was like you want to go
outside so he puts the collar on her
and then she goes run into the front
door like so he can go sit she can go
sit on the porch
and then he and then she goes to the
door he opens it and then she looks out
and then she puts her little back up
like
nope and then turns around like comes
back in the house
she has her little back arches
like it's like [ __ ] with me she
didn't want to go she did it again the
front door i opened the front of the
front door like that she walks up to it
and then just lays down
[Laughter]
she's looking outside that's right okay
all right
you're her [ __ ] tom
yeah yeah
open up the door just get up to it just
lay down look outside she's like haha i
got daddy to open it she got me
she does that's it
well i was telling them how she always
does that thing where she like she yells
and yells and scratches and stuff and
then you open it and then she sticks her
head out and then she arches a little
back and goes nope yeah yeah yeah too
hot
don't like it i just wanted to see if
you would open the door thanks
it hasn't quite cooled off enough
it's in the 80s but
when it gets into the 70s that's when
she goes out more
yeah i get even animals they they know
what's they know what they know how it
is they know what's up yeah they feel
the same way i do like when we open the
door and they're like oh [ __ ] this
i'm going back in the ac
uh dom the bomb says i'm late is jenny
and tom moving
we've had like every new person that
every new person that got well i knew
that would probably happen because like
i said we we first talked about it on
sunday but that's like a movie review
day so probably a lot of people didn't
well you you give them the rundown
because i have to pee okay
yes we're moving
but it's a good thing
the landlord wants to swap houses with
us he's too old to walk up and down the
stairs
so he wants this house because it's a
single floor and he knows i took care of
this [ __ ] he's like yeah you did good
and he goes
normally he would have kicked me down
the road
but for the same amount of rent and
everything he wants to be moving a house
is 50 larger it's like three 3 500
[ __ ] square feet
house 10 miles from here and eustis were
kind of where i wanted to move
big old two-story house just like this
one
got like three living rooms and [ __ ]
five bedrooms and
three and a half baths and big kitchen
it's gonna cost more to keep it cool in
there at the air conditioning
but i just can't pass on it and i got
two months to move
it's gonna give me the key friday i can
move slowly over there over the next two
months just taking [ __ ] in the cars and
i can it's empty now
it'll be ready on friday that's when the
painting is finished and i can go in
there and [ __ ] you know it's got new
carpeting upstairs and uh
so i got a good deal
i got a good deal he's
it's because sucking
[Music]
never was laid out for the rent in 10
years and [ __ ] took care of his [ __ ]
and uh he wants somebody in there he
also offered me the option to buy it for
the same price as this
and it's 50 larger
yeah and it's
it's an area that
i used to live in that area about a mile
two miles from there when i worked in
the horse industry it's outside eustis
he used to live in that area for lived
there for like two years
it's changed a lot in the past 10 years
it's grown up
it's like this place was when we moved
here 10 years ago yeah
um it's not rural out there anymore it's
like uh the edge of [ __ ] it's the
edge of
of the uh of suburbia the beginning of
horse farms yeah even across the street
from the neighborhood is a huge horse
farm yeah which i like that area it's
never really going to get built up like
it is here it's just a little too far
out
and too many
people own too much land out there i
think
yeah i mean at least they've built some
stuff so because like i said i was kind
of worried but when we built when we
went out there yeah a couple days ago
they had just built in big new it's got
a shopping complex
with the public and everything it's got
a [ __ ] sushi restaurants and
everything you know you can chinese
restaurants and
it it's built up quite a bit a lot of a
lot of [ __ ] drug stores you know
[ __ ] what's the event drug stores
over there walgreens or cbs or whatever
cbs something like that so
it's not as um
country as it was
yeah because like i said i don't want to
live out in the middle of nowhere
but
and i'm saying country and it's not
country like mississippi country nothing
could be like that
yeah it's not like deliverance or
anything like that where it's like you
stop at a gas station and no one has any
teeth and they're gonna butt rape you
out there is kind of like san diego
1978-79
it's like that
if you're in california
excuse me
seeing pookie like go back and forth
across she's like so anxious she was so
i was in here this morning like cleaning
that
closet out over there and like starting
to pack up some stuff
what are you doing and i bought
i bought this um a whole [ __ ] ton of
moving boxes and they came like in this
much bigger like humongous box
and i had it laying on the floor
you know while i was like pulling them
out and unfolding them and taping them
and stuff and it's like and i looked
over i looked behind me
and i saw the box laying on the floor
and all i saw was pookie's little butt
sticking out like she'd stuck her whole
like front half like into the box and
like her little butt was sticking out
and that little bitty tail was just like
wagging like that she's like ooh look at
all this [ __ ] i found it dom goes yeah
it sounds like a good deal man same
price a good deal yeah it's the same
price
it's the same price i raised my own rant
on this [ __ ] when this pandemic
happened i i told him i said look i've
been here for nearly 10 years man
[ __ ] you haven't even raised the rent
i mean our landlords are awesome and
he's like yeah no they're really really
nice
so i raised my own rent by what 300
bucks a month
yeah well it wasn't fair
yeah
i mean they were giving us like really
honestly to be honest
um we pay
1800 yeah for this house which is like i
said a 4-3 and that includes law
enforcement
and housing
and the hoa hoa um and honestly if you
look
um
even
like more toward downtown orlando or
like some higher end areas it you can't
even get a really nice apartment for
eighteen hundred dollars i was fixing
[ __ ] in here and showing him and then
he's like how much is don't worry about
i would never charge that dude for
fixing anything in here well yeah in
here like i said if it was big [ __ ] like
fixing the out like the eight the ac
yeah they can pay for that or they can
pay to paint the outside place and
faucets replacing toilet seats yeah a
little [ __ ] like that no i was doing all
that yeah i don't i don't mind it and
[ __ ] repaint it in here
uh i didn't charge him for any of that
and uh that's part of it being
i [ __ ] uh you know i served my liege
lord [ __ ]
okay
and it's like some medieval [ __ ] so you
know me being his vassal he took care of
me [ __ ] in these hard times of civil
unrest he put me in one of his better
homes for him you know well the thing
about them
the property of the lord the thing about
them though is that they own a lot of
properties so it's not like
you know it's not like they're hurting
no they got if we're charged like a
little bit less than they got 13 of
these things because they got like 13
houses that they own outright
that they rent out
they're landlords yeah they're from
poland like houses like this yeah well i
think he's from poland and i think she's
from spain
isn't she from spain
i thought she said that yeah i think
she's from spain my stepmom's from
poland yeah they're not
i i don't even think they're american
citizens but they live here
yeah yeah they're good people
his son is like american as apple pie i
met him you know
yeah they've been over here like a few
times
but yeah that's what i mean so
you know we were worried
well we weren't worried that they were
going to kick us out because they
wouldn't do that i know they wouldn't do
that like we knew they wouldn't do that
because i thought they were going to
give us time and that would either but i
thought they were gonna say either buy
this house or you have to get out i
didn't actually expect them to be like
oh hey
have this other house for exactly the
same price that's much bigger after the
show dom go back and look because i
talked about it we showed it
we showed it to the people about a
[ __ ] hour ago
i was just planning on [ __ ] looking
for houses to move into and to buy and
for under 400 000 i found a damn mexican
castle that was what we would have got
we're not going to have that one but
it's still for sale it looked pretty
damn cool we actually had an appointment
to go look at it yeah before we found
out that the landlord so we're getting
80 000 or 395 395.
and it's got the address and everything
i show it yes if anybody wants to move
here and live like a colombian drug lord
that's the [ __ ] house it's a gothic
spanish style house with mexican wood
that came out of a and lighting fixtures
and weird and it's all gothic and it's
came out of them
mexican [ __ ] like catholic churches
churches in it it's cool looking real
cool thailand that's cool looking tile
on the bottom floor top floors got teal
[ __ ] that's ugly you'd have to tear
it's like
ricardo monteblond's pleasure palace
from 19 [ __ ] 75 the house was built
in 1950s and it's [ __ ] stone yeah
and um it's cool looking though it
looked very cool but
we didn't get to see it because this is
offer i can't refuse so
yeah i mean that's the thing we had an
appointment to go look at that other
house because we assume it's a little
further out than this so yeah we assumed
when they said hey you know we're going
to that they were probably going to sell
this house so we were like well [ __ ] we
have to start looking for another house
so we made an appointment to go see this
other house
and but then they came over and said no
no it's like we're not going to sell
this house we want to move into this
house but we will give you this other
house so we're swapping
um you know so we didn't actually need
to go look at that other house then but
that other house is super kick-ass so if
anybody like wants a really cool looking
house like that yeah invite me over to
parties because i want to like look at
those beautiful lighting fixtures
[Laughter]
mr bus is the goth dream house
it's a it's a dream house if you're into
like dia de los muertos it could totally
be made because i was like looking at
the pictures i'm just like oh i could
goth the [ __ ] out of this i would have
made it mexican without much effort yeah
just the
day of the dead style [ __ ] gothic
yeah see that would have been safer yeah
it's like you do watch it well you can
make it look like you can make it look
like a mexican catholic you actually
can't church like you could put some
[ __ ] stained glass in there you could
go whole hog man yeah
you could put a lot of cool [ __ ] in it
let me cost a lot of money to get it
done though
true but you know
i don't have to be a pain i mean see the
thing is i'm confident my own artistic
skills i can draw and i can paint too i
could have painted a bunch of cool [ __ ]
in there
it's just that boy you get tired of it
man at my age if i was in my 30s well
you know i could [ __ ] just increase
my testosterone [ __ ] injections and
be like yeah yeah yeah
start bumping a bunch of [ __ ] anavar
and [ __ ] and painting what's gonna say
get some cocaine cookies some cocaine
yeah i'll go call my [ __ ] cocaine
drug dealer friends and [ __ ] yeah i'm
honestly
honestly even though we're not going to
like the mexican gothic house which is
funny because i just bought that i just
bought that book mexican gothic which
i'm going to be reviewing soon yeah but
um the house we're going to
um
i'm kind of excited i got all kind of
plans about at least what i'm going to
do with the i know what i'm going to do
with the office and with the office
bathroom
the other stuff is still kind of up in
the air although i do have some ideas
like i said we might have to do it like
a little bit at a time because you know
i'm not made of money obviously
um office and studio is going to be
first priority because that's going to
be on camera
so
i'm going to do i'm going gonna get all
that [ __ ] first yes it was a cool house
and it was like living like a colombian
drug lord it's exactly what it would be
like
it looked like uh it looked like
something you'd see out of a damn movie
just bunch of bunch of arches and like i
said it had i'm pretty sure it had a
real retro it had a dock you had boat
access yeah yeah it had it it was across
the street but it was your property it
was like a strip yeah it gave you a
strip that went down to the damn lake so
you could put a boat in the water you
had lake access yeah and you could like
if you had a boat you could like keep it
there but yeah it did look like a pablo
escobar type
it said retro pablo escobar looked like
something out of a [ __ ]
out of [ __ ] pain and gain movie
like if if you were gonna make a [ __ ]
movie about [ __ ] mexican or mexican
drug lords in in in
in [ __ ] florida yeah that was it
it's cool though i show pictures of it
i'm not gonna show it again man it took
too much time yeah
but after after the show post you can go
back and look in you'll see me i'll show
it to the camera it was good it was cool
house built in the 1950s
yeah that was the only thing that kind
of i was just kind of like ooh is it
going to have to be rewired or is the ac
like gonna be [ __ ] up or whatever um
so yeah so
so zach just showed up hi zach uh so
when are you moving and how big is it
and then david june says restart the
show zach it's been covered several
times yeah well every time like a new
person shows up i always feel like
because everybody has been asking yeah
it's a two-floor house like this
well no this is just one floor no it
looks like this but it's two floors yeah
it's 50 larger 3 500
square feet whereas this is 24. this is
24. and it has one more bedroom one more
bed and a half
and an extra bathroom and an extra
living room in another living room
so it's much much bigger much bigger
it's 50 larger than this yeah same price
about 10 miles up the road yeah same age
as this house same style basically yeah
it looks about the same but it's kind of
yeah it's the same kind of neighborhood
it's not gated but it's the same kind of
thing it's in kind of a location i
wanted to go it was where i used to live
about 10 11 years ago 11 12 years ago
it's out near the horse farms
it used to be real rural now that's the
edge of suburbia because it's getting
bigger everybody's moving here
this is getting [ __ ] gentrified man
today they just doubled the width of the
road out here to a four-lane [ __ ]
road i mean i knew they were doing
something out there because yesterday we
went to
uh where did we go yesterday
the bank bank yeah and then somewhere
else yeah um and or the movies or
wherever
wherever the hell we went
the other day and they were all kind of
and there were all kind of trucks in the
road and like the truck was kind of
blocking the road and they were like hey
road work and blah blah blah i didn't
realize that we're going to be widening
the road like in a day holy crap they
doubled it
wow
yeah that's why well like i said even
before we moved here it's getting busy
along that road
yeah and well because the road like if
you come out of our neighborhood like
there's two entrances right we live near
the back entrance of the neighborhood
but there's also like a big main like a
main entrance a mile up and if you come
out of that it's just like a two-lane
well it's two lanes on either side right
or no it's just one lane on either side
i was thinking of the turn lane so it's
like it's kind of a small road because
it used to be rural
um
but they've built so much [ __ ] along
there hell they built a whole new
neighborhood
right along that road like behind like
in front of our neighborhood they built
like a whole it's not like it's probably
like a dozen houses we moved here this
is the only neighborhood like this yeah
in this area
now there's [ __ ] five or six of them
and and
[ __ ] high-density apartment complexes
they're real good quality
but
the the population density is [ __ ]
skyrocketing we're right off i-4
everybody's moving here from new york
and california it's just
we got to go it's getting gentrified
too many y'all here
i like to be on the edge of the [ __ ] and
it's still we're not out of the way we
still get the mannequins we can still
get to i4
and we can now go to tampa because they
got that new freeway oh yeah and that's
another thing they are building they
built well most of it's built they built
a new freeway
that is like a toll road but it goes
right from here to town to tampa so you
can bypass i-4
35 which is always good because i-4 is a
[ __ ] nightmare at the best of times
although it's better than it was because
they have been working on it they have
been widening it means you can get to
tampa in under an hour which yeah you
couldn't do before before or not so
that will be easier probably get to tap
on 40 minutes if you win 80.
i mean it's a toll road but that's okay
yeah i mean you can buy the i got to buy
one of those um
what do you call it's the
the tolled thingy that you put in your
window i used to have one in my old car
limit here 70 miles an hour
nobody's going 70.
everybody's going 80. cops are going 90.
real fast traffic here
well except during except on i-4 when
everyone's you're not when no one is
moving because everyone's just sitting
there except rush hour on i-4 yeah it's
like a parking lot i should know because
i used to drive on it like every day
honestly even when
and i used to work kind of weird hours
like i worked
we lived here in sanford
um and i worked at a place
uh even past downtown orlando it was off
sound um orange blossom trail
and so
that was even
like an hour at the best of
times and i wouldn't get off work until
6 30 p.m and it took me like an hour and
a half to get home yeah i'm gonna take
videos of the house before everything
gets moved everything gets moved in
don't worry about it and then once it's
kind of like all when i get my office
and [ __ ] all done yeah something i'll do
like an office tour
and show everybody yeah i'm going to
show you guys everything because i want
to do
like i said i wanted to show you guys
the sex dungeons or
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] arsenal of full auto weapons
and [ __ ] body armor and [ __ ] we're
gonna show that
once the office is all done because
that's gonna be i mean at least that's
my first priority like i said because
that's gonna be on camera
so that's gonna be the first thing i'm
gonna like fix up all nice
um i'm going to fix up all the other
stuff nice too but i don't have to you
know the office will be the first thing
so as soon as the office is done i'll do
like a hole we get the keys yeah just in
case you guys missed it
we get the keys on friday and we have we
have to be out of here in two months
after that yeah so we got plenty of time
it's only 10 miles up the road i will
only have to rent a truck for a couple
times maybe twice
two days because like i said we don't
have i mean what's got beds refrigerator
oh yeah that's right
washer dryer oh that's right the washer
and dryer is ours oh wait sets
yeah okay so we wanted the motorcycles
there we will need a van yeah we'll need
a van but we only but we probably only
need to take like two trips yeah two or
three because what do we have two beds
yeah um
you know the weight sets yeah a couple
couches some chairs although the chairs
a lot of glass tables
yeah
there's a lot of people we don't have a
[ __ ] ton of furniture a lot of uh it's
mostly just the big stuff
and you and and and oh [ __ ]
what the generators oh yeah crap the
generators and then i forgot about all
the [ __ ] in the garage yeah and then i
got yeah well see the thing is is that
all the garage and storage stuff has to
go first
because we don't use it
yeah so you might as well use to move
things that you're not using well yeah
that's what i'm i see
in florida if you're wise
you have
at least one generator i got two
all right
and then i got at least five air
conditioners
four of them are window units one of
them is a central unit yeah okay we had
our power knocked out during a hurricane
and i don't want that [ __ ] happening or
your [ __ ] central air goes out in the
middle of the [ __ ] summer it's gonna
be weeks before you can get somebody out
to look at it because they're all
[ __ ] busy
so you better [ __ ] have window units
or you're gonna or you're a dumbass of a
heat strike and you can get a window
unit for 125 bucks so i got a bunch of
them
yeah i'm not stupid yeah you just hook
it up we went we just plugged it into
the generator yeah we went through
[ __ ]
one [ __ ]
outage and [ __ ] we didn't have it for
about five days and i was [ __ ]
miserable never again
never again well like i said i've been
through a hurricane before too before i
met you like when i lived at my old
house and our power was out for eight
[ __ ] days yeah wow that blew yeah in
august i think no maybe it was september
but it was still like 95 i got two brand
new generators
one of them can run a bunch of [ __ ] it's
a honda and the other one is this
[ __ ] damn blue thing that can run the
whole house
this house i don't know if it'll run the
whole other house but it even including
the central system but i gotta get a
special hookup for the outside that croc
costs about 800 bucks to get the hook up
that way you can just attach the
generators to the house
and run the whole house off the [ __ ]
gas gym yeah because before we were just
had to like extension
because we just wanted the you know the
window unit and the fridge right mainly
um and then something to charge the
phones right that was about it i got
solar [ __ ] now i can charge all the
phones and everything but that's right
now we can have it then yeah with that
back then yeah i got a bunch of solar
[ __ ] i can charge
zach said didn't you say jenny has a
library in the attic once too yeah i
might no it's not a library do i have
more do i have more it's um okay we've
got all the christmas decorations up
well i know all the christmas shit's up
there and we you got a bunch of stuff
like
dishes from your old apartment
and pots and pans
well i'm gonna look through those
because i'll probably throw those away a
bunch of tapes
well no i threw out all my cassette
tapes i'm pretty sure okay i think
there's some records up there
there's uh a bunch of i thought yeah
okay a bunch of artwork i mean honestly
i threw out all my cassette tapes i
think
like last purge that i did
i sold almost all of my vinyl and i
think the only vinyl i have i have like
this many like vinyl records left and i
think they're in there
so i don't think they're in the attic
but i don't remember what all is in
there i got a lot of tools
i got three sets of tools two of them
gotta go
too many tools
too many tools too many yeah you got all
you got a lot of fun i don't even know
what the [ __ ] all is a lot of cordless
[ __ ] that needs to be thrown out
because the only thing of mine that's in
that garage is that bicycle and that's
old and i can throw that out okay
because i can buy a new bike bicycle's
going there bicycles are cheap okay
bicycles going i'll throw all that [ __ ]
out i mean it's the the [ __ ] we got
time shane is [ __ ] up we got two
months to throw all that [ __ ] up not a
big deal
like i said honestly at this point i'm
just kind of like most of my [ __ ] i just
want to throw it away and buy a new
shirt buy new [ __ ] now i'm gonna sing
kind of the same way
if you don't [ __ ] with it in 10 years
you're never gonna [ __ ] with it that's
what i figure it's like i need to go
through everything just to make sure i
don't throw anything important like my
[ __ ] birth certificate or something
but it's just kind of like or my way
doesn't garbage go out tomorrow
yeah we have to put some garbage outside
i pulled out
from that closet because remember when
we built like that uh the soundproof
booth in there and we had like all that
cardboard like i pulled most of that out
all right um so we got to put that on
the curb
and i threw out like a whole like big
garbage bag full of stuff all right out
of there but i'm a clean house on this
bus i haven't even like this time but
like i said i'm excited about it because
it's something i've been wanting to do
clean house on [ __ ] it's just i
haven't got around to because i have so
much stuff got to travel more light i
mean most of the [ __ ] we're not using
yeah and it's just like i was going
through like i went through my office
drawers and like some of the [ __ ] in
there today and i was just kind of like
why even do i have some of this stuff
yeah
i don't need it prepper pov his name is
prepper he just got the solar power
station i was looking at the solar power
station the big one
and uh
some of that [ __ ] you can um
charge it with your car alternator you
could put it in the back of a car or run
a whole camp for [ __ ] weeks
they got wireless [ __ ] recharging see
it's a 21st century [ __ ] we have all
kind of cool [ __ ] now there's ways to do
it's about a grand yeah
but uh
good to have something like that yeah
especially in an emergency if you have
power outages i would i mean i would i
would say like just living in florida um
you know for me growing up here it's
always good don't like go whole hog or
anything
but it's always good to have backup
measures like that because we do have a
lot of hurricanes and honestly even if
there's not hurricanes sometimes if it's
just a really bad storm which we have a
lot of every summer yeah um the power
will go out yeah i always keep a
stockpile of food that i rotate through
too because there's no
having lived through [ __ ] hurricane
katrina
man you want a couple months food easy
for everybody in the house
that way just
if something bad happens
you can eat for a couple months
you gotta be
until [ __ ] until normalcy is [ __ ]
restored normalcy normalcy is
getting restored you try to say
normality or mammals at the same time
i'm [ __ ] drunk
yeah you are but uh
yeah [ __ ]
spam
[ __ ] sugar
flour
oil powdered milk
[ __ ] dried [ __ ] all that dried
stuff and the big number 10 cans you
know i got all kind of nice canned soup
i'll just yeah i'll just drink that
right out of the can well i also
got also got all those dried clam
chowder
dried soup mixes dried this and that you
know what i mean [ __ ] basically dried
hamburger helper in packages
that you could just eat
you want to keep you go
i know so many people are [ __ ]
worried about emergency stuff whatever
could happen you know anything could
happen
the priority some people are making
mistakes they're buying [ __ ] that
doesn't have any damn food value yeah
you can buy a lot of ramen cheap i dare
you to try to live off a ramen for a
week
ramen has a lot of calories but it
doesn't have a lot of nutrition there's
no protein in that
and that [ __ ] will [ __ ] your guts up
okay
it's just filler
it ends up being sugar i mean i like
ramen but i like ramen
with other things
i like boiled eggs in it yeah mushrooms
with the japanese use ramen as a filler
yeah okay it's fortified with eggs and
ham and urchin eggs and spam
meat fish that you have to fortify that
for emergency stuff
uh and you know for those who don't know
me i know you [ __ ] are all regular
the military will and emerge my military
duty taught me the [ __ ]
the primary food source of all human
beings whether you think you're a vegan
or not is [ __ ] protein
if you're not getting protein you're
going to get hungry
and you're going to lose muscle mass and
you're going to get weak
carbohydrates
and sugars like protein like [ __ ]
noodles and [ __ ]
and bread
that's not enough you can't live off
that
there's no food to that
you need protein
if it can't be meat you have to get some
of that protein powder for
that you buy and a big old thing for
bodybuilders did get some nuts
even that is not that concentrated it's
very high calorie it's expensive and
there's not a lot not as much protein
that powdered whey protein that you
drink vanilla flavored actually
three or four scoops of that a day you
could actually live on that as long as
as long as it was mixed with something
because
there is a food
element to it there's protein
you can't have that kansas spam
all during world war ii the american
army survived on spam primarily spram
spam and crackers
that's some wild [ __ ] that's bram spam
and
crackers spam is not a low quality meat
it's pork shoulder that's a high quality
cut it's cooked in the can it's just the
problem with it is it's very salty you
want to get that low sodium spam
the flavor spams even better you can
dice it up and put it in your ramen and
make a big difference
you can eat a can of spam a day it's
[ __ ] survive even the low sodium spam
is still too salty it's still a little
too salty yeah it's too salty
so
when possible what you do is you take
any kind of spam i mean i'd eat it if i
had to but i'd prefer not to
it just makes me thirsty what i do is i
take that spam i slice it thin and try
to fry it get some of the salt out of it
um in an emergency situation
you want to uh you want powdered milk
and you want powdered eggs
and you can mix all that together the
powdered milk the powdered eggs and the
spam
together will keep you
in good nutrition for long term you can
live on that
would you enjoy it no
we actually tried out the powdered eggs
the other day because you wanted to see
if they were any good they're not good
they're okay but they don't really taste
like eggs they taste funny they just
taste they don't really taste like much
of anything here's the thing the reason
why we ate those is because those came
packed in a plastic bag
and that was the cheap ones
i can't trust that packaging it's not
the exact same ones that i have in the
metal cans
see that's what happens every now and
then we have all this like stuff and
then he's like well i gotta get rid of
this we gotta rotate this out so let we
gotta eat this eat this so we gotta eat
these powdered eggs or yeah whatever it
is which if it's just an ingredient like
it's just powdered milk or something you
can do like a million things with that
but powdered eggs like powdered eggs
have a funny flavor you yeah what you
made like an omelette or something like
that with them and it's like it was okay
but it didn't really taste like eggs no
because man i love eggs i could you know
what if somebody told me that i couldn't
eat
that i couldn't eat meat anymore but i
could still eat eggs i'd probably be
like okay
the the reason why
you want them is one they're shelf
stable forever
you only need water to produce to to
finish them water and heat
and uh they contain protein
you know what i mean they're nutritious
pookie i said stop it she's not gonna
she's trying to go outside you want to
go outside
yeah
first lie to me
good
thank you david craving shrimp and grits
got a good recipe there's one in our
cookbook although i can't remember what
it is offhand
uh secret though is use
you have to ask tom but
we got this from
uh chantal
from the restaurant her shrimp and grits
she uses uh i think she uses coconut
milk in it
and they're really really good
but yeah
i don't think we have coconut i don't
think he puts coconut milk in ours but
she puts coconut milk in hers and it's
like really really good i love shrimp
and grits
yeah well um somebody asked us before if
we did any gardening
we don't like we did like little [ __ ]
like you know
we had some
growing some basil and stuff
but
uh david g and asked we had a good
shrimp and grits recipe i said there's
one in the cookbook
but then i said chantelle had that she
told us she put coconut milk in here
instead of cream you can also put
coconut milk it's great
and her and her shrimp and grits are
really really good yeah that's that was
that was uh
chantal's local
soul food
uh um
twist on on shrimp and grits
and uh
i must attest it is great
now here's something else
i got lots of grits
i love greens grits
was the emergency rations of the south
during the civil war
they lived off grits and heart attacks
and [ __ ]
the problem with grits grits taste good
but it's like ramen
a lot of calories there's not much
nutrition in it
no protein
those confederate [ __ ] we had a
buckle five back then okay they didn't
weigh anything now they weigh a thousand
five
because a guy has a lot of muscle mass
that's not going to be
satisfied with grits it has to be
fortified grits
and spam diced fried spam in the grits
is [ __ ] great you can do that
there you're getting your protein
if you wanted to add
coconut milk to that
if you go to the
cans of coconut milk are heavy they
weigh a lot they're kind of expensive if
you go to an indian or middle eastern
store you can find
powdered coconut milk yeah that's what
we always used to get yeah and way
cheaper that'll last forever
okay and it doesn't require
refrigeration or power
so if you can [ __ ] find powdered
coconut milk that's a good thing to have
on hand
another good good and i've said this
before in other shows
go to walmart go to the hispanic aisle
and go get you some of that neato dried
milk that's what i use now because i
don't we mostly drink almond milk just
for the calories yeah i don't think we
have any regular milk in the house no if
i need regular milk i got that damn
neato i'll make up a
a [ __ ] cup of that [ __ ] to put in a
recipe to put in a recipe we don't like
drink like in on cereal and stuff we
just put almond milk it's almond milk
it's the calories are a lot better
but that neato and they got two
different kinds of it the regular and
the fortified the fortified is good
enough for for children to put in a
bottle
um
but they're both good
if it's chilled
and it's mixed thick enough
you know you're not skimp skipping on
put a lot of water when it's cold you
can drink it just like milk now is it as
good as fresh milk no
but it's it tastes good
you can i don't mind it yeah i don't
mind it like in a recipe yeah you know
what i mean like if i'm pouring it on
cereal or
putting it in coffee or something you
were starving i'm not gonna just drink
it out of a glass though if you were
starving or you were hungry okay
thank you dom the bomb what do you say
jenny will you be watching halloween
kills when it's released yeah we
probably will see that uh did you watch
the prequel halloween 2018 as well
yesterday yeah we saw that in the
theater it was pretty good i remember
i remember it was pretty good but yeah
we'll see it when it comes out i saw the
trailer for it the other day
if you were hungry or you know what i
mean a [ __ ] nice glass of that
powdered neato milk has it been sitting
if it sat for a little while and made
sure it was nice and blended and you
threw some nice cold ice in that thing
and drank it you'd love it it's good
especially if you had a little bit of
damn
nestle's quick in it
although to be honest out of a glass i'm
going to drink milk out of a glass i'd
rather drink almond milk
almond milk to me tastes better than the
powdered milk the powdered milk could be
more nutritious though i know that but
i'm just saying that
taste wise i think the almond milk is
better right for survival reasons
purposes you want some that powdered
milk that's what i'm saying you want a
lot of that we got a lot of that yeah we
have like big things of it well like i
said for cold milk like in cartons we
just we always get almond milk i don't i
don't think we have any regular no like
gallon milk no i use neat i use neato
for [ __ ] um recipes
yeah yeah it works out a lot better
because you don't because you see things
that we don't the reason why i did that
is because we don't use much fresh milk
it would go sour
i don't even think at the moment do we
even have any cereal in the house no i
don't think we have any cereal in the
house oh no we have a [ __ ] ton of uh we
got a [ __ ] ton of oatmeal lots of it
right but i just put water in that i
don't put milk in that you can though
i mean you can but i don't
because why that's just excellent you're
just talking about cereal
i'm talking about cold cereal yeah that
you would pour milk on because because
oatmeal is a cereal i know it is i don't
know i know it is but uh well actually
yeah yeah yeah well actually that's
that's not um no i know cereal but we
don't have i'm talking about you know
what i'm talking about cold cereal that
you would pour milk on no but we have a
lot of i know you can make oatmeal with
milk yeah like the package because we
just have the quaker
open like the maple yeah what maple
sugar i have really i just mix those
with water i think i have two things i
don't know
they're old we i need to use those up
and replace them quaker oats remember in
the round can yeah that's good to have
yeah they make good oatmeal cookies
[Laughter]
it makes good oatmeal bread there's all
kinds of i'm telling you right now we
got that we got a big bag of walnuts in
there because i just went in there and
the other day and ate a handful of them
it also makes excellent uh it makes
excellent meatloaf
a lot of people forget
yeah it's a good filler good bread good
everything
mmm oatmeal yeah
[ __ ] like i said i even like the
packaged oatmeal
like the fla i like the flavored ones
because like i said you know at sam's
they have
two different varieties where you can
buy like how many packages are in there
like 50 packages or something
packets
and they have one that's like fruity
flavors it's like strawberry
strawberries and cream peaches and cream
and blueberry [ __ ] that one the
strawberry one's okay but the other box
has maple brown sugar
cinnamon and apple and cinnamon that's
that's my jam right yeah i like um
cereal
but dollar for dollar oatmeal is a lot
more nutritious more bang for the buck
cereal is candy
you know what i mean like that depending
on what kind it is and honestly
yeah i mean i i like oatmeal yeah the
nice thing about oatmeal too
is that
um it helps you get your cholesterol
down
because i actually got my cholesterol
down quite a bit just by eating oatmeal
every morning any highly processed grain
is
high in carbohydrates it's not that good
for you
carb
oatmeal is not really a processed
grain so it's better for you a lot
better yeah
more nutritious and like i said it's
good in hamburger
yeah you can use it for a lot you use it
for a lot of stuff and like i said it
makes amazing cookies just don't put
[ __ ] raisins in it
well raisins are good in it too no
they're not we've got
raisins and craisins and all different
kinds of things that you can craisins
are good i don't mind like putting cause
because i was saying we made oatmeal
cookies before and we put walnuts in it
and craisins and that was fun but
raisins raisins thank you esther esther
said his [ __ ] ten dollars would you
love you tom and jenny we love you too
love you too babe oh
um how are you doing on that drink it's
almost it's almost empty okay buckwheat
pancakes yeah that's good yeah man we
haven't had pancakes in a long time uh
yeah i made pancakes those [ __ ]
sucked and i looked and i checked the
[ __ ] pancake mix the pancake mixture
here's another yeah this is what
happened
we have so much stuff that happened he's
like oh we have this pancake mix with
this is probably old we need to use this
up so he made pancakes they didn't rise
and they were kind of they were okay but
they didn't they were kind of like just
mediocre and then he was like oh this is
two years old that's probably two years
out of date i didn't realize that they
had the [ __ ]
damn well what are you gonna do that
[ __ ] was cheap though that was from
sam's
yeah you can buy like those big huge
bucks sam's has really what's it like a
five pound bag like a five pound bag of
[ __ ] pancakes pancakes
for not much like six bucks yeah and you
can't eat them all
well that's the thing that's the only
thing about all that thank you zach i
love buying granola and trail mix and
using them for cereal in the morning
yeah see i like i like some substantial
like crunchy
action going on
you know they got people that make their
own cereal by doing that kind of stuff
yeah
you can make your own candy bars out of
that
well ever i feel like more people are
into that nowadays like doing kind of
like breakfast bowl type situations
where they're pouring in we're gonna put
in some granola we're gonna put like
some yogurt like some greek yogurt in
there and like putting more like matcha
powder they're putting all kind of stuff
in there like mixing it all up together
you know wheat germ i don't know what
the [ __ ] they're eating nowadays
[Laughter]
all that kind of crap yeah granola is
like pretty easy to make
you gonna get new drinks soon
pookie's still in right
yeah she pretends like she's gonna go
out and she goes nope
she knows what she's doing
yeah like i said she she has got you
wrapped around her little tiny
um
her little her little jelly bean paw
or her little chicken leg as i call it
i call him her drumsticks well because
her little her little head and body are
like really really round and kind of
chonky
but then she has these little bitty
short legs and these little
these little tiny feet and it's like so
a lot of times she'll like when she lays
down she just sticks her legs out
straight like that so she's got like
this little round body like these little
bitty short legs just sticking out like
that and i said they look like little
bitty drumsticks so i'm like look at
your little drumsticks
she doesn't know what i'm saying well
probably she does probably she does
zach has paid up for five shows yeah
i don't know i've kind of thought about
making my own granola
i do love granola
i hardly ever eat breakfast though now
that i'm thinking about it
honestly i get up really early because
like i said this morning for whatever
reason honestly as soon as the sun comes
up unless i drank a lot the night before
and i'm like really tired
um
i will wake up like as soon as the sun
comes up like the first light comes over
the horizon and i'm like doink and i
wake up
and i can't get back to sleep so usually
this morning i woke up a little bit
before five
and couldn't get back to sleep
so i laid there for a little while
trying to go back to sleep and i
couldn't so after a while i was like
[ __ ] it i'm just gonna get up and start
packing because or and cleaning the
closet out so i started doing that at
like [ __ ] 6 30 this morning because
i'm a crazy person evidently yeah she's
crazy but
i never
i hardly ever eat breakfast
i will have
a cup and a half of coffee
and a glass of water for breakfast and
that's it
i used to eat breakfast i don't know i
like breakfast i just feel like i never
eat it i just never eat it i have coffee
a lot breakfast a lot of times yeah but
by the time you get up yeah and by the
time you make breakfast it's usually
like lunch time
no it's about 10.
well no because this morning you brought
you gave me an egg salad sandwich but it
was like almost 11 o'clock yeah that
wasn't at that point that's like
lunchtime it was lunch
yeah that's what i mean but i also
see see this is how she does i made you
a a mickey omelette sometimes although
yeah but that was but that was later
that wasn't like i'm talking about
breakfast like right because
sometimes like i said i'm not being mean
i'm just saying that i get up like a
long time before you do not her servant
so a lot of times
so when i'm saying breakfast i'm talking
about i get up and then i make something
to eat like right when i get up at like
seven in the morning
i hardly ever do that
so it's like
sometimes you get up and you'll make
like an omelette or something but that's
usually like 10 11 o'clock so it's like
brunch time that's like not breakfast
that's what i'm saying
because i'm talking about i'm talking
about breakfast like
when i get up which is like 6 30 or 7 in
the morning
almost always unless i'm unless i've
drank a lot the night before and i sleep
a little bit later but usually
as soon as the sun comes up i wake up
whenever i want
because carpenter he's not going to be
making he's not going to be making
movies i don't think anymore carpenter's
old bro
wait is he still alive i don't know he
may be dead but i thought he died he
died
and um
or no maybe i'm thinking like well wes
craven died that movie there told you
what it needed to tell you it told you
the truth it needed to tell you
esther says tom and jenny the
relationship show
it's [ __ ] ridiculous that's [ __ ]
ridiculous well it's a well it's weird
because i'm just saying that like i have
a different like schedule
that's all so it's like sometimes you're
just like oh it's breakfast time and i'm
like [ __ ] i've been up for like five
hours already what are you talking about
it's breakfast time it's like if i
wanted breakfast i would have eaten it
five hours ago
that's all i'm saying
i'm not oh i feed you when i'm ready to
feed you
yeah i'm gonna put my
this [ __ ] this second haircut is
ridiculous this [ __ ] weird i honestly
i think that wig looked a little bit
better on me it probably would
well i put it on one time to see what it
is where's the cone
where's where's the [ __ ] no comb oh
where's calm
see this [ __ ] got dirty mine well it
sounded like you said no comb there's
that brush and also i found i didn't
know i had this i think this came with
one of the wigs yeah but look at this i
have like a little weird
i don't even know why they gave me this
but look at that
i think it came with one of the wigs i
think like one of my wigs
this [ __ ] here [ __ ] that that's what i
mean it's probably probably cost like
twenty years no i ain't buying
oh you don't like it no
it's so pretty [ __ ] hair
[ __ ] hair i'll just put some goggles on
i'm waiting for my leather daddy hat to
show up where the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] go
this [ __ ] hat that i got going zach's
gonna love this hat this hat is gay as
[ __ ] hold on here put that over there
it's a i got a [ __ ] leather daddy
bondage [ __ ] hat it's like straight
out of the [ __ ] third reich looks
like a [ __ ]
you're gonna have actual ss [ __ ]
policeman you're gonna have to wear like
somebody's my
leg because you know how i have some of
those hard i have like these like
leather harness kind of things i'm gonna
get me a [ __ ] no i got it well i have
that one like leonard leather harness
thing that has like little leather angel
wings on the back you should probably
wear that if it was yeah i could do that
but i got if it would fit yeah it's
going to be for my rob halford outfit
yeah yeah
i got to [ __ ] you should do that for
halloween just let the jacket [ __ ]
come well now that we're now that we're
moving and we have to like buy furniture
and now i'm like where i'm like [ __ ] can
i even afford a halloween costume maybe
i just have to like put something
together from what i have already
which i gotta check to see when this
shit's covered because [ __ ] man now i
can't afford to do like a costume i'm
going to have to like i mean i can if i
can do a costume i just have to do
something with stuff i have already
instead of buying something else i had
to [ __ ] buy the damn also buy and pay
september 8th is when i'm supposed to
come damn should have been here [ __ ] was
shipped this september 8th
yeah that was a long time ago what's
today the 13th where's it coming from
space
track it i'm trying to track it
zach said you're still not his type
that's not due to you zach
there's nothing dude stop [ __ ]
flattering yourself do you remember
though that like two seconds ago you you
said that zach would love it
yeah so you called him out specifically
i'm gonna get that [ __ ] vest for it
what the [ __ ] are you gonna [ __ ] up my
lighting again
i'm gonna get that [ __ ] vest for it
that's nice yeah
beowulf said just go as cat burglars for
halloween
i have to think of something better than
that i just have to think of something
that i don't have to buy something
there's the [ __ ] basic hat i'm gonna
dress it up though
that's the hat oh my god yeah that's
what it looks like you're gonna get butt
worked randomly that [ __ ] right there
it's gay as [ __ ]
that [ __ ] there's [ __ ]
that's just for violently homosexual
violence you're homosexual right there
you [ __ ] up my lighting again okay
yeah you did
fix it
fix it
you can see my pores i don't like it
thank you
there you go
[Laughter]
that's just sexy man
gonna put skull and crossbones on it
tom's pretty sure tom's pretty sure he's
straight
i'm gonna have a [ __ ] belt i'm gonna
have a belt with a [ __ ] leather whip
honestly if you're okay so if you dress
up like that for halloween
i'm gonna dress like that for the show
well for the show we'll like go club for
that whenever you do it for the show you
should ride the motorcycle into here
yeah ride the motorcycle into here come
on into the into the office yeah that's
right with chaps on yeah i mean you're
going to have a g-string
not even have pants on just a g string
you can see your little butt like like
the alien saw that night when you ran
out into this exactly it'd be just like
like wes from [ __ ] blade from [ __ ]
road warrior there you go yeah yeah can
i put a leash on you
no i'll put a leash on you
no that's not how that works you don't
put that you don't put the [ __ ] you
don't put the leash on the on the top
um
on the top
this is not it's not dominant it's not
it's not i'm the dominant one it's not
fun anymore see that's not fun
this is not a game you should be
involved in jenny this is oh you don't
you don't think so no it's [ __ ] just
between men what are you talking about
15 minutes okay whatever see now she's
getting chills
i'm not jealous i'm trying to [ __ ] i
just don't care anymore he will not
look i ordered all this [ __ ] paint
one thank you zach
that's not violently homosexual it's not
what is what i did to my buddy nick in
the restroom at the nature trail last
week
oh my god i'm gonna wear that [ __ ] to
i'm gonna wear that [ __ ] the [ __ ]
mannequins when [ __ ] toby's in there
we're gonna be the two leather daddies
i'm on a dance floor
that would be funny you can get you can
get that [ __ ] on video and we're gonna
show that [ __ ] on the show he likes to
dance with me though yeah
everybody likes to dance with you
i'm a good dancer yeah
did you know that kim jong-un lost all
that weight
why would i why would i do that look at
that
oh [ __ ]
it's brand new look look at him you got
skinny he got skinny
okay kim's shot stop it what are you
doing
you need attention
is that what it is come here
she's being a little she's being a
little bratty head today yeah what are
you doing well she's a little brat all
the time yeah because she's always like
pay attention to me i'm just going to
like scratch it says tom's going to get
asked as chaps that's what you're wrong
because chat don't have it all chaps are
[ __ ] all chaps are asses chaps are
naturally assless
they go on over your jeans i've met some
people that were naturally asked nasty
you see
but if you're gonna get [ __ ] like
ultra [ __ ] masculine all right ultra
[ __ ] violently homosexually masculine
you're gonna get and you you can verify
this [ __ ] with zach you're gonna put
[ __ ] g-string on
and then put chaps on
g-string or as i like to call them anal
floss anal floss with a funnel cup
for your package
and then you're going to put the chaps
on because it'll show the facial
delivery it'll show the front and the
back because people forget that chaps
are not only assets they're crotchless
too they just cover they just go around
your belt loop and then they just cover
the sides
the sides of your sides your legs in the
front of your legs sort of it's a
western but not your crotch
no
you're supposed to be wearing pants
supposed to be wearing well it's
supposed to be supposed to work that's
the operative phrase in that situation
sure
those cowboys yeah they were all power
bottoms
[Laughter]
they may be a powerbomb
broke back
mountain actually man brokeback mountain
was such a good movie did you see it i
saw it i saw it in the theater it was
really good
i didn't see it when i heard about it it
was just kind of like a joke you know
people thought well i know everybody
makes a joke about it but no it was good
it was a good it was good
yeah it's a good movie it was kind of
sweet
that's something that [ __ ] girls and
[ __ ] gay dudes would want to watch
[ __ ] gay cowboys
i'm not into cowboys i just thought it
was like a nice stretch it's definitely
fetish man [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh johnny rotten would have
[ __ ] loved that [ __ ]
he he wore the gay cowboy shirt in texas
on stage
i think he just did that to like get
somebody matted he almost got his ass
beat
well yeah
that was kind of his whole shtick back
in the i'm gonna wear the most defensive
thing possible yeah and darry to beat my
ass going to texas [ __ ] in front of
all those rednecks wearing a gay cowboy
shirt that was a pretty famous like a
lot of people wore that shirt back in
the day it was a very provocative yeah
type of thing to wear because man
those cowboys and [ __ ] are so sensitive
what you're wearing a shirt with a
picture i don't like
dude chill well i have shirts in the
shirt they weren't really cowboys they
were just bondage dudes i know i've seen
that shirt like i said it's a famous
t-shirt
it wasn't just johnny rotten i was like
a lot of people wore that yeah um a lot
of people wore those no i'm saying like
a lot of people like kind of punk rocker
it's kind of like people wore those
because they knew that it would like
piss rednecks off that [ __ ] guy because
rednecks are very sensitive and
snowflakey and it's very easy to like
that [ __ ] actually it's very easy to
have found though that [ __ ] came out of
the [ __ ] sex claw at the sex stores
let's see who sold that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that shirt yeah the gay sex [ __ ]
shows
well actually
i don't even think they just had
everything in those [ __ ] sex stores
they really so sold stex toys
before they had it online see
well we had one here up actually
fairvilla it might be still open it's
big it's two stories
and the bottom floor
is pretty much all just clothes a lot of
them are like
sexy clothes
um you know bondage type stuff but they
have like a lot of cool like gothy type
clothes and [ __ ] like that all the sex
toys and all that kind of stuff are on
the second floor
so they have like a lot of stuff it's a
superstore
it's probably still there where tom
where is toby toby's probably working
tommy's a nurse
he's not honestly working yeah yeah he
works a lot he works a lot he doesn't
even come out all that much yeah we see
him like maybe once every couple of
months yeah when he comes out it's like
a big event man [ __ ] everything he
used to come out every week yeah well i
you know i feel like all of us old
people used to come out once a week and
then like various things happen and we
just don't anymore
like now i'm like i'm too tired filbert
grimm the third says tom i'm gay also
and a leather bottom okay [ __ ] a cool
man yeah i understand all about it
[ __ ] um
me [ __ ] growing up as a kid you know
in brazil
in the
80s i started off i love [ __ ] heavy
metal music
okay the heavy metal scene was [ __ ]
big back then
the god scene had not really formed yet
they didn't have the kind of music that
would interest me at that time or i
wouldn't have come wouldn't wouldn't
have come across
much of it
although some of the early stuff i did
come across i did like it
just that as a teenage boy you liked
[ __ ] metal back in the 80s i was a
big iron maiden fan i [ __ ] loved iron
maiden's first two albums and i [ __ ]
[ __ ] loved [ __ ] uh judas priest
a big fan of the music that they had
there in the 70s and the 80s
rob halford real impressed with him
um
and i also liked [ __ ] uh a bad a
german kind of a german version
of
of vegeta's priest called accept
and [ __ ] they had a little [ __ ]
short funny look at the singer named udo
dirk and snyder
and you know what's funny is that
in those days me and the other guys that
listened to metal at our age we were
like 15 16 years old
we didn't really pick up on the [ __ ]
um on the gay leather daddy
undertones of of judas priest and accept
at that time
i guess he's just not really old enough
to [ __ ]
interpret what somebody is saying in
lyrics you're kind of projecting your
opinion of what is being said into these
lyrics
and
rob
rob halford from judas priest he was you
know he's a master lyricist
real good
i mean to this day he trademarked the
name metal god i mean he was a god his
voice was just the [ __ ] the greatest
he's old he's still rocking he doesn't
sound as good as he used to but he still
[ __ ] puts on a good show everybody
knows the god who god is you know it's
[ __ ] rob all right
i remember i was about
probably about 16 or 17.
why can't i stop sneezing i don't know i
have something wrong with you and then
um
there was a [ __ ] album i really liked
70s um judas priest
he had a album called sin after sin
and on that album was a song called raw
deal there's no lyrics
there's no lyrics involved
inside the lyric jacket inside inside
the jacket
and i'm going what the [ __ ] is this dude
talking about
and i didn't have the cultural
references to know what
fire island was or what a leather cop
was and all kinds of but you look at it
now man [ __ ] rob halford came out
back in [ __ ] 77
i even knew what fire island was in the
early 80s yeah but then i was a kid i
was in brazil though okay and in brazil
at that time and in brazil i didn't know
what fire island was
so
how rob had come out
[ __ ] you know now by the time the
turbo album came out i saw [ __ ]
rob live at [ __ ] biloxi stadium
during the turbo lover tour by then you
know a couple years later [ __ ] it's
obvious to me that [ __ ]
rob is gay and he's leather daddy but it
didn't matter it didn't even matter back
then
come on
it didn't matter
[ __ ]
he was kind of like um
he was a [ __ ] great artist he still
is great artist he's a great artist he
had real good musical taste he put on a
great show
the lyrics were really good
he knew how to [ __ ]
make some macho ass [ __ ] i mean that
[ __ ] understood it like the
[ __ ] what was the name
dissident aggressor off of sin after sin
the sad wings of destiny album a [ __ ]
tyrant and genocide the ripper
[ __ ]
man [ __ ] um
what was the one the song of center
just you know what i mean he was just he
he knew how to sing and he he he knew
how to [ __ ]
sing to dudes which i guess being gay
helps you to do that you know how to
sing to dudes you know
but that's just the way it was because
you know it's art and art is emotion and
putting on as the show is emotion you
know
um so now
now do you have to be gay to deliver a
good [ __ ] metal show no
no not at all most of those dudes
weren't you know [ __ ] i don't think
any dudes from metallica were or [ __ ]
iron maiden but it didn't matter and it
didn't even matter back then it's funny
how these young kids are talking about
with those this lgbt acceptance i don't
know what they're [ __ ] talking about
because there was acceptance even back
then but maybe it wasn't as
mainstream but
who gave a [ __ ] about the mainstream
well they're all freakazoids
the thing about it though is that it i
think it was easier for us because we
were kind of like in a subculture that
was didn't see it didn't you really give
a [ __ ] as a big deal but
i definitely remember people older than
me being really really homophobic and
being really really racist and [ __ ] like
that like even in the 80s and 90s so
just laughed at them i know but it's
like it was something that was around so
it's not like you can say oh they didn't
know what was going on because that
totally was going on i mean like i said
just because
you know we were in a subculture that
didn't care about that
but
you know in in a lot of ways people
picked on us in the same kind of ways
because they thought [ __ ] about us that
wasn't true
i think that there's today's today's
[ __ ] society is all about acceptance
and i was always rebellious i never
wanted acceptance i didn't give a [ __ ]
if they accepted me then [ __ ] [ __ ]
them
well i don't even think well the thing
about it is that you don't you don't
care if they necessarily like what
you're doing but it's like i don't
really want to get [ __ ] with by them
either i don't want them like throwing
rocks at me or like stopping me from
doing stuff yeah but you know what's
funny
most of them people that we're talking
about they're dead
and good riddance most of them are dead
now
yeah sorry i was laughing at something
that david june said back here my uncle
tom yes that was his name yeah uncle tom
i was an uncle tom too did it yes
yeah didn't believe me when i told him
that halford was gay yeah he's an old
school priest fan i think a lot of
people didn't believe it even though
looking back on it now duh it's super
obvious
um but it's just funny that so many
people were like no he's just like
really no i remember i remember the
mentality
back in those days because of
stereotypes you thought when you said
gay you thought of it a very effeminate
guy well because that's what was seen in
the media that's what they showed you we
kind of like talked about this a little
bit because like um the review that we
did for this week which was the man who
fell to earth i had forgotten that in
that movie
there is a gay couple
in it that you don't even know that it's
like not even it's just played like
totally normal and totally like nobody
comments on it you don't find out
they're gay until the end and i was kind
of like watching it going wow that's
like super progress like for the 1976
whenever that movie came out i was just
like holy [ __ ] like nobody commented on
it like the guys weren't like
because you know how in a lot of 70s
movies
they put gay characters but they'd be
like over the top gay like oh my god
girlfriend like they'd be like that yeah
and um damon wayans style yeah and
they'd be like wearing like crazy ass
clothes and it'd be like way over the
top which and i know like some people
are like that and like no no hate i'm
not hating on you but i'm just saying
that that was like a stereotype and it
was played for comedy
um and the fact that they would actually
just put a normal gay couple in a movie
and nobody said anything about it
um
kind of blew my mind from like 1976. i
just wasn't used to seeing that yeah uh
back in those days you know what i mean
uh a gay male the stereotype was very
effeminate yeah
and
halfer didn't have that
appearance in public from what you saw
of him
um now if you see some of his live
performances you could see he's got he's
got a little bit of magic in his step
you can see he is gay
but
it wasn't a holy it wasn't really
[ __ ]
prominent in his pr
of the times he just seemed to be like
[ __ ] real like macho and you know
what i mean well like i said because of
media the way that you know gay people
were portrayed in movies and tv shows
and stuff if they were portrayed at all
they were portrayed like i said as comic
relief so it would be like way over the
top like super theatricals they were the
same yeah so be like way over the top so
i kind of feel like maybe
a lot of just regular ass working-class
people or whatever they didn't know any
gay people in real life or they didn't
think they knew any real gay people in
real life so
the only perception that they have was
was from media so it's like well if
they're not like swishing around
like paul lind or whatever then it's
like well then they're obviously not gay
so i kind of because they didn't have
any context yeah there was another thing
was is that mainstream america had no
concept of bdsm
or [ __ ] gay
gay [ __ ] leather fetish bdsm scene
they didn't know about it they didn't
know that that was a thing
so when you saw
when you saw judas priest she didn't
realize that their their that their
motif in this style and the way they
were dressing was gay bondage
yeah that's where that came from
but there was also cross crossover in
[ __ ]
punk rock punk rock kind of wore the
same things and johnny ryden johnny
johnny uh
lyden and [ __ ] or john lyden and
johnny rotten she [ __ ] [ __ ] it
johnny rotten and [ __ ] um sid vicious
we're not gay
um but the thing about punk is god had a
little bit of a
fetish
one there was a lot of crossover
crossovers with the gay community and
also
the whole punk thing was all about
shocking the squares
so it's like anything that was going to
be like offensive or was going to like
freak people out
they were going to at the same time this
is going on you got the new romantic
scene
so you got
duran duran
and abc and all these guys [ __ ]
showing up and adam ant
and you're thinking well those dudes are
gay
no those [ __ ] they were super
they were super headers aggressive
[ __ ] hetero predators thank you it
was it was kind of stylistically
for
the straight suburban [ __ ] kids and
everybody else it was stylistically
confusing for them to know who was who
it was all just a big yeah [ __ ] it we
just like it all because we liked it all
yeah we liked it all right well i i
thought that the dudes from drandream
were gay
until i got a little older i realized to
go no no way i did not those
i thought david bowie was gay no
david bowie was
a closeted heterosexual he was a fake
homosexual
i don't know like to me like even from
an early age
i guess because
when i wa even when i was a little kid i
was super into like goth [ __ ] and i was
super into
new wave and punk and stuff so it's like
the gender thing it didn't really
like i didn't really see why it was a
big deal i'm like you can just like why
don't you just taylor what's up tina's
gotta go and she says scott what do you
want to say where you been tayla
god damn there she is yeah i was like
you're a dude you want to wear a dress
okay you're a woman you want to dress
like a you want to dress like annie
lennox and sweet dreams okay
yeah it i was like is it hurting me no i
was like you like it it looks cool so
i'm not bothered i didn't even notice
any of that [ __ ] i'm not bothered well
that's what i mean well the only reason
that i noticed it was because i'd have
like my grandpa yeah would be like what
are they all are they all gay with the
book are they they're all gay and
they're all on drugs and
they have an earring and eyeliner
and i'm like dude and i try to explain
i'm like dude that doesn't really mean
anything yeah but even when i was a kid
i was just but you know that they didn't
get it filler said tom toby could tutor
me in college for nursing
but yeah it's just
you know i don't i don't know it's just
so
in a way it's kind of hard
intellectually like i know that
um
you know mainstream society i guess you
want to call it that like it took a lot
longer to
catch on to stuff but because i was into
you know like i said because we were
into like goth and punk and new wave and
stuff like that like early like from
early 80s
where it wasn't really that big a deal
so
in a lot of ways i kind of felt like
when finally like when people were like
oh it's not a big deal i'm like oh my
god welcome to
where i was like 20 years ago you know
you know what i mean it's just kind of
like it's it's exactly everything
goes even in the old movies they were
always the decorator yeah
yeah it just seemed like
when they put would put a gay character
in there and they wouldn't even like
back in the old days you couldn't say
that and he's also said phil burdock
says thomas so right the leather world
was so underground at one time it was
yeah it was
the leather world
was only in the 80s it was only in the
little repediograph
black and white fanzines
that came out
that they would trade for munch and so
was the goth scene at that time
but uh that's how gay the leather world
was
it was so underground remember what they
call radiograph the little machine
the mimeograph mimeograph fanzines they
give you the paging yeah about what
clubs are where and [ __ ] photographs
of dudes you know what i mean we saw
some of those yeah but um they just kind
of circulated like you know people one
person would have it in their house and
like make one because there was no
internet no so uh nowadays it'd be on
the internet but back then you had to
make your own little fanzine what we
call them the god scene was like that
too yeah
and there was some crossover
you had important
gays in the goth scene
well because they could come hang out at
goth bars and no one would [ __ ] with
that yeah and they made magazines like
the dude that did propaganda yeah yeah
propaganda magazine man i bought every
issue yeah they were big into like
goth pretty boys dressed up as nazis and
[ __ ] and kind of sexual [ __ ] it's like
bondage leather types yeah the guy that
started it was a photographer yeah the
main one was uh the main kid that they
would take pictures of
was uh my friend tanya's ex-boyfriend
was his name he was dave dave uh
he had his own band for he had his own
oh i know who you're talking about i can
see his face i just can't think kodiak
there you go koviak what's his name cut
no
coziak kovya with a z
or koviak with a v koviak what was his
name
it's one of those things
i know you're talking about i've seen
him show i'll show you guys pictures
yeah i've seen uh yeah i i have john
koviak yeah yeah yeah john kovac and he
was in a band
beautiful what was the name of that man
[ __ ] man i'm gonna show you some john
koviak yeah
i had like yeah i had a bunch of issues
of propaganda i had the first one i sold
a bunch of my propaganda issues like uh
a little while back but if you guys
haven't if you're
one of my friends from boston she was a
she worked for chanel
and her name was tanya
she ended up getting married to a guy
named voltaire who had a goth band he's
pretty famous well he has a delightful
youtube channel called the lara voltaire
where he does goth homemaking before she
what's up before she was married to him
she kind of was like friends and messed
around with a dude named john koviak who
was like a big goth
scenester kid yeah who also was in the
beds
but he was in propaganda magazine a lot
as a model yeah the guy who owned that
magazine was kind of a gay leather type
dude yeah he's a photographer
photographer but he was real into
[ __ ] the goth scene and leather too
and the fetish
i'm gonna show you some photographs of
that because that's gonna be on internet
like i said i like i used to love
propaganda i had a bunch of bunch of
issues like i said recently i sold some
of them just because
i needed the money so like i sold a
bunch of the i had i actually had the
first issue i think
the first issue were like a really
really early one where it was still all
in black and white like later it went
all the full color but i had a black and
white one
i sorry i was laughing at this picture
made this comment okay there's john
koviak
yeah i remember that picture all right
and that's like something out of
propaganda that was kind of like the
nazi fetish sexual kind of like our
version of [ __ ] bondage oh let me
show you there's more
i remember that one um a novel i wrote a
long time ago that i don't think i ever
published
one of the characters in it i think i
like the physical description i kind of
based on him because i had some pictures
of him that were in propaganda and i was
kind of like oh that's cool i can basic
character around that guy
that's what i did
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
child spazz all right
yeah there was a lot of that kind of
stuff a lot of that kind of stuff back
then
and um
yeah i don't even
do they don't do propaganda anymore
today oh god
that was all yeah i remember that yeah
see i remember all these pictures that
was all a um
what do you call it a
kind of a
vanity project that magazine i don't
think he made any money but those issues
are worth a lot they are well because he
only put him out
i think he put out well yeah he put him
out quarterly yeah at first they were
only black and white because i had a few
issues that were just like the black and
white issues
um but then he went full color like
you know kind of a thick
binding type of [ __ ] and it was just all
like photography there was articles and
[ __ ] in there too but it was mostly like
photography based
and fashion based yeah
see if i can get that
i remember one picture of him in
particular where more he had kind of
more of like a death hawk i don't think
it was a death hawk but it was more like
a spiky
all the girls liberty spikes all the
girls love this yeah that's super hot
yeah
that's super hot
victor said when i was in sixth grade i
pierced my ear but i accidentally
pierced the gay side and i've like dudes
ever since then
[Laughter]
it looks like martin gore in that
picture yeah
that all goes back to like martin gore
from depeche mode and guys goes back to
like death in june and all the german
germanic gothic folk stuff that was
going on
i wish i could remember the what was the
name of the dude that founded propaganda
i know his name but i can't think of it
right now
my brain's too
um pickled
but yeah i used to really like those um
the propaganda
issues because like i said they only
came out like four times a year
so you'd go i had to get them at i used
to buy them at um well i bought them at
atlantic sounds in daytona beach which
was our little
independent wrecker store record store
which was owned by
what's up she's trying to go ahead
just sit on the porch or in the bushes
but yeah we had a little record store in
daytona which was owned by um
a guy named eric that was a couple years
older
and he was like super into like you know
goth and punk and everything and he like
had a little bit of money and he opened
like this little bitty record store
so we had that we had a um another one
called atlantic sounds which have been
there a long time and it's like so they
were super into like indie [ __ ] back in
the 80s so that was where you went in
daytona these no says i'm not gaming my
boyfriend is yeah
that's a little joke [ __ ] come on yes
[Laughter]
but it's just kind of like
i don't know didn't punk start in london
i don't know because i kind of feel like
well new york probably i kind of feel
like it was more a new york thing and
then
because new york
they had cbgb's they had the remote
yeah um and honestly even before that
we're going back to like [ __ ] detroit
we had like [ __ ] the stooges and the
mc5 which was kind of like proto punk
um but then new york had the velvet
underground which was kind of proto goth
so
what do you i don't know i i don't even
know if it started anywhere because
i don't know
like i said i've heard some like [ __ ]
from
you know some stooges [ __ ]
that sounds kind of like some punk rock
and that was like [ __ ] 60s that was
like late 60s
so
what are you gonna say what are you
gonna say when it started i don't know i
don't i don't know if i'm gonna get into
that debate because i know there's a
whole thing about like oh did the
americans started the brit started
grandpa says i read an interview once
where mary lynn said she dabbled in
lesbianism for a few years but
eventually returned to the sausage
[Laughter]
i'm going to say i'm going to confirm
returning to this
no [ __ ] maryland was always uh
that's my ex-girlfriend if you guys
don't know but [ __ ] marilyn marilyn
was always kind of uh she played around
yeah
and she told me that when she went to
[ __ ] hollywood it was
it's a scene you know what i mean
[ __ ] shit's gonna happen
[ __ ] might happen today around here we
don't know you know that [ __ ] happens
well that's kind of the thing you don't
ever know you don't ever know you might
run across some some you're you might
meet somebody right across some girl and
you shit's gonna [ __ ] throw down and
you're like i said i'm open to that yeah
you [ __ ] [ __ ] happens i'm just like i
said i'm all about
me and jenny have [ __ ] been in a
position where like
okay we're gonna do this well yeah
that's what i'm saying it's just it
happens it's just kind of like well and
that's what i'm saying about like that's
i think one of the things that always
kind of like that i liked about the goth
scene even from a very young age is that
it was just kind of like no one was
really everyone's just kind of like
whatever you just like who you like i
just like this person i don't care what
gender they are what genitalia they have
or whatever it's just kind of like i
just like that person david and everyone
was like all right
philbert says those pictures are good
yeah they're good there's more of them
too all right oh yeah they're online
um i just showed you some of the like
yeah just look up like propaganda
magazine david serviette
yeah john john covey john covey yeah
and uh just look photographs you'll see
honestly just look up propaganda
magazine like photos in general is
because they have like a bunch of other
models besides him david goes tom
recreate those pics once you get your
hat that could beat those picks dude
and now see the thing is is that it that
at that time and that place for that
for that magazine's demographic
the guys that were gonna rise to the top
were skinny
young dudes
because
the market was kind of actually if you
looked at who was buying the magazines
were i want to say fat but
slightly overweight female
heterosexual or bisexual girls they
[ __ ] love that [ __ ]
never goth
that was who was buying it and and uh
that was probably the biggest number of
them
um then there were
gay goth dudes of that age
and um
straight [ __ ] hottie or bisexual
[ __ ] goth chicks we're into that [ __ ]
too yeah um well everybody loves like a
scrawny goth boy yeah goth straight
dudes like i you know
i liked propaganda but it was for the
artistic content and all the other [ __ ]
and it was kind of like touching base
with the scene of what was
aesthetically the vibe for the scene at
that time was it was like a little bit
of a taste maker right it was kind of
like the goth version of cosmo
it was but not as trashy
but i kind of feel like it was almost
like the goth version of the new yorkers
yeah yeah yeah it's good that's that's
that's because cosmo is like super
trashy yeah yeah god version of new york
like 10 ways to drive him crazy in bed
yeah yeah yeah
every other issue right
i had a friend that read that in high
school
she used to like give me those quizzes
and the good thing about what i liked
about [ __ ] propaganda and the goth
scene at that time
at that time metal was totally
mainstream and totally conformist and
[ __ ] basically [ __ ] white trash
okay
goth was [ __ ] subversive and real
exclusive
not everybody could be a goth about at
that time that's why we were so snotty
right now yes we're still we're still
kind of snappy about it
[Laughter]
that's okay and it was and it was also
designed to piss you off i mean that was
nazi [ __ ] nazi visuals well like i said
even susan the banshees and this is
going back to what i was saying about
punk
punk being all about being provocative
um they wanted to wear [ __ ] that would
offend you they wanted like they wanted
to cross dress they wanted to wear like
swastikas they wanted to do something
that people they wanted to do to provoke
a reaction that didn't mean
like just because susie for example wore
a nazi uniform at some point or whatever
were a swastika that didn't mean she was
a nazi she was jewish yeah that that
just meant she wanted to like piss
people off that's what they were trying
to do because they thought that everyone
was like it was too yeah you weren't
trying to fit in they were subversive it
was they didn't want to fit in they just
wanted to [ __ ] everyone off like i said
and yeah [ __ ] susie wore a swastika
for a while she was jewish yeah that's
that's how much of a [ __ ] you it was it
was just
it was a rebellion against the
mainstream
and it was also rebellion against punk
rock
because punk rock had gotten kind of
trashy they started to go more
disciplined more stylistic
more 1920s flapper 30 1930s with
medieval stuff
more ethnic
was part of the flavor
more traditional almost but then mixed
with [ __ ] bdsm
which was
it was just the times
it was meant to inflame
but like i said that was what i always
liked about it is that not so much it it
has an identity but it also is like um
kind of vast enough or flexible enough
to incorporate a lot of different things
into it yeah i mean it was always like
really
open-ended
open-minded
um
i don't so much i i'm not really into
like provoking people just for the sake
of it i think that's dumb and little
juvenile
nothing is funny is that i'm telling you
what i'll tell you i think it's funny is
that some people that's so ridiculous
just gay nazi stuff
oh the nazis weren't gay the nazis
weren't getting you don't know who ernst
rome and the sa were yeah that was the
whole thing
oh yes they were ernest rahm
who was the main instrument behind the
rise of the [ __ ]
german national socialist movement
was a world war one [ __ ] leather
daddy he was a
spartan warrior homosexual predatory
homosexual
and hitler was one of them
all right that's gonna people have a
hard time wrapping their minds around
that because of the modern gestalt he
was one of them
he knew that that would never accept
that mainstream germany would ever
accept that and during the night of the
long knives he betrayed rom and the sa
and killed most of them
and sent a lot of the sa storm troopers
to prison or sold them to the earth made
them join the german army
because he had to choose between either
the sa or the german army he chose the
german army because that was mainstream
the sa was a bunch of leather daddies
and a lot of this was slowly purged
out of history
because
and the american system doesn't want
people to know that
but no
the sa was gay as [ __ ]
in a spartan kind of way
and you know that has been history up
until very recently but it's all been
purged though
oh everybody's saying that when we move
into our new house we should have a big
party and invite all of them yeah right
we're going to invite [ __ ] thousands
if you can all like fly here
you got to like
byo play it would be boring [ __ ] it'd
be better to have you [ __ ] meet us at
mannequins
and then we'll tear well i mean they
could all come here and then we could go
out to them and then we can't go
well not here but like to the new house
that might be fun everybody can meet
pookie in person
she would freak out and hide under the
bed
who were all these people
the thing about pokey is that
it's weird because beijing
is so aloof
normally
but if a new person comes to the house
she will come right up to them and
she'll be like hey what are you about
i'm gonna rub on all your stuff do you
mind
but if uh and then pookie who is like
super super friendly and super hey i'm
gonna follow you everywhere
if a new person comes to the house she's
like [ __ ] this and she goes and hides
under the bed for like hours and hours
and then finally she'll peek her little
head back out and be like are these
people gonna hurt me
okay i'll come out and maybe and then
she kind of checks it out
it's weird it's weird that she'd be shy
i would have thought that it would have
been the opposite but it's not
bring your own sleeping bag fly yourself
there that's that's that's what they
said that
uh levy from motorhead collected a lot
of nazi memorabilia he collected a lot
of world war one memorabilia and world
war ii memorabilia from [ __ ] all
sides though
lemmy was definitely not a
nazi sympathizer of [ __ ] he was dating
he was dating mocha
who is a a black porn star
from the 90s that was his ex-girlfriend
so he lemmy was just wild he here's the
thing about lemmy though
lemmy is a lot more intelligent than
people might think that he would be he's
very smart
and he [ __ ] loved [ __ ] world war
one and world war ii
mechanical history he could tell you
everything about all those tanks and all
those aircraft the history behind him he
was typical guy he could tell you you
know oh i know everybody who designed
this and that how fast it went and
[ __ ] can't remember my girlfriend's
birthday birthday but i remember like
all the world war two planes yeah all
the world war two planets
[ __ ] he could tell you all that
and uh
let me love tanks he was big into armor
stuff he'd have been probably a good
soldier if he wasn't so wrapped up in
rock and roll and drugs and [ __ ] but he
was he understood it he was a good dude
[ __ ]
it's bad that he died but we all go
and i'll tell you this
lemmy left by left behind a very solid
musical [ __ ] catalog he will always
be remembered he was a good dude well
that's the thing about him is that he
never declined really yeah i mean it's
sad that he died obviously just like you
know it's sad that david bowie died
inside but you know we can still like
listen to their [ __ ]
and they made an impact on the world
like on millions of people so yeah
that's more than most people can say
just just saying yeah beezness says my
cat someone just knocks on the door my
cat starts running and hiding uh pookie
kinda does that too if the doorbell
rings like if amazon brings a package or
something she flips out and hides under
the bed um she doesn't even like the
garbage truck going by the garbage truck
goes by and she's just like oh
and she runs and hides i said lemmy was
in some trauma movies yeah i'm sure he
probably was
trump made so many moves yeah you really
need to see more of those yeah
you would probably like
tromeo and julia everyone i've seen of
like
are monstered yeah
i kept saying that i kept seeing that
one in blockbuster and i'm like should i
no
i don't i can't do poop i was talking
[ __ ] the other day i was talking [ __ ]
the other day about [ __ ] um
the movie that we saw what's that last
one we saw about the [ __ ]
about the monster
the last we saw this week we saw it this
week uh at the theater or theater
what malignant malignant yeah okay i was
talking [ __ ] about malignant i said
malignant was kind of like something
about a
out of [ __ ] um
man i'm [ __ ] drunk i came back what
was what what is
i don't know asylum it's kind of like
something out of asylum yeah
but there's a couple of silent movies
that i've seen i [ __ ] really enjoyed
them [ __ ] nazis
at the center of the nazis at the center
of the earth [ __ ] with [ __ ] busy
with [ __ ] junior boosie that [ __ ]
there was [ __ ] baby boosie yeah
uh that was pretty funny that was a
masterpiece
i got it on blu-ray yeah we have one
nazi's at the center of the earth
it holds up
it holds up to [ __ ] german to to
german
science fiction from the early 1900s and
everything it's it exactly everything
about it is [ __ ] correct
in many
ways
the movie was [ __ ] sure well that's
what i mean it's like just because you
say something's like low budget or trash
or whatever that doesn't necessarily
mean that because look at for example
velocipaster but yeah they wrote the
[ __ ] out of that movie
i mean somebody that knew what they were
talking about exactly what they're
talking about wrote that movie yep
about the hollow earth
and [ __ ] the vril
and the [ __ ]
hannah boo the hannah boo flying saucers
and [ __ ]
undead angle no they didn't have that
but [ __ ] adding it was all right yeah
that's okay that's okay yeah
uh dc maniac says malignant i'm going to
sign off now and yeah victor said
malignant song it was i like i like the
malignant i get it check out
like i'm not all that invested in it i
get why a lot of people didn't like it i
enjoyed it but i can see how you would
hate it
i can see i can see how people would
hate it because
we did a whole show on it yeah we did we
explained it it wasn't um
it wasn't anything like the trailer no
um and it was like ridiculous and over
the top and like i said i can see what
he was going for he he achieved what he
wanted
yeah he's like i'm just gonna go full on
[ __ ] ridiculous
[ __ ] audacious
i'm gonna do some brian de palma [ __ ] it
was a throwback movie in a certain way
in other words then there was like a lot
of deception in it
he's like he starts off with the sound
it's like a [ __ ] movie
from asylum it almost looks like video
game cut scenes in it
and then it gets kind of serious like
something out of [ __ ] the conjuring
series well yeah and then he goes nope
that's not what kind of movie this is
this is an action movie
[ __ ]
we're going to get it action movie yeah
but honestly i had to let i was kind of
like all right yeah all right because i
wasn't expecting that but you have to
understand what's what hollywood's
problems
all right there's other channels that
will cover it you'll have hollywood
insiders who understand the [ __ ]
studio system and the market and all
this pandemic and this [ __ ]
civil war that's called that's brewing
and everything
the [ __ ] industry is [ __ ] broken
okay
they can't get people to come into these
[ __ ] movie theaters in enough numbers
to really justify their existence
everybody's streaming now
i have the amc
service right we can go watch movies
[ __ ] three of them a weekend all
right for 20 bucks
all right now three of and that's a lot
of movies per month
yeah that's actually a pretty 12 movies
a month for 23 dollars i think that's it
but here's a weird thing there's also an
an additional bonus there's a bonus
feature that some of these movies you
can stream to your house
so what the [ __ ] do you need to go to
the theater for eventually they're going
to close those amc theaters down and
it's just going to be another app
although hey i still get free sodas and
popcorn you get sometimes yeah i still
got some free popcorn coming that's a
business model that business model is in
transition it's not going to work i
enjoy getting out of the house and going
down there and hanging out as long as
it's kind of dead in there i don't want
to be in a [ __ ] theater full of bunch
of [ __ ] talking and farting and
[ __ ] leaving their message chewing
and chewing [ __ ] you know
nobody else does i'd rather watch these
movies [ __ ] drinking and going hold
on pause it let me take a piss be back
in a minute that's a lot better okay
but there is something kind of nostalgic
about going to a theater and sitting and
watching it like there is and driving
there there's a certain amount of ritual
to it
well i kind of like it that's why
generation though i kind of like it
because i can turn my phone off yeah i
don't have to check my email for too
like you're doing something which is
nice the thing is is that younger
generations don't see it that way
they're like why do i have to be here to
see this i'd rather watch this on my
phone it's that really how they well the
thing about it and this is what they did
with malignant was that it came out in
the theater but then they released it
simultaneously to hbo max
so if you wanted to stream it at home
yeah you could also pay and stream it at
home
or you could go see in the theater so i
kind of like that they're giving people
both options like you don't have to go
to the theater to see it
you know you can pay to see it in your
house
their business model is not a business
model that will [ __ ] ensure long-term
success
in a tumultuous world
that you're having right now a world of
pull
polarity and division
a world where the internet is dominating
a world in where
[ __ ] live streaming is beating things
in a world where video games beat
hollywood consistently
most of their [ __ ]
most of their audience has left and
they're pissed
and they're almost kind of like a
[ __ ]
jealous psychopathic ex-boyfriend or
ex-girlfriend you left me you
[ __ ] and a lot of the [ __ ] that
they're doing on these movies is kind of
crazy
and this movie is kind of like
exemplifies that
they're desperate
everything's already been done
so they have to start playing these
weird ass games to at least get you to
remember the [ __ ] movie
so it is a [ __ ] show you people know man
that movie was a [ __ ] show
yeah it is a [ __ ] show hollywood is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show the theater system is
a [ __ ] show
the whole [ __ ]
studio system is a big ass [ __ ] show
those
those [ __ ]
celebrities those actors and actresses
are a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
look at how they act on twitter
my recommendation is to enjoy this [ __ ]
sit there and watch these [ __ ]
do this [ __ ] it is it is kind of
hilarious or don't and find something
better today but
this is the end the tail end of an older
american culture that is reaching
obsolescence
that's okay it's okay it's fine but it's
just funny watching this [ __ ] flare-up
flail around
was malignant good
uh
no
was it entertaining yeah yeah i liked it
i was entertained i was entertained i i
understood the message that it was
trying to give me it was kind of a
throwback because i liked that it went
just like what the [ __ ] there's like
whatever and i'm just kind of like all
right i respect your decision so at
least i remember that one yeah
jenny and i went for like a couple of
years watching this [ __ ] was it a year
or two years that we did the [ __ ]
probably two years close to two because
we started out doing matinee like at the
theaters remember that yeah the vast
majority of those movies were
forgettable as [ __ ]
yeah even though like a lot of times we
enjoyed it at the time but if you know
and i remember seeing them but i
couldn't tell you yeah what most of them
what it was about yeah mostly just
forgettable they make lots and lots and
lots of like i said just make the [ __ ]
crazy yeah so might as well just be
crazy with the [ __ ] so you remember at
least i'll remember it
[Laughter]
well that's what i'm saying well that's
what i'm saying it's much better
to make something that is like
horrifyingly horrifyingly bad yeah than
to make something that is like good but
mediocre
well they're in a conundrum because i
see a lot of movies that are like pretty
good yeah
um but then like a year or two down the
line i'll be like what was that maybe
about i saw that right
yeah i remember it was good but it
didn't like stay with you yeah like
those marvel movies at the time you're
like yeah it was okay but then you can't
remember a [ __ ] word that's what i
mean i can't remember anything that
happened to them but shazam i remembered
venom i remembered because they were
unusual
yeah you also you have to do something
like different you have to do something
different like to get people to remember
it so
and like i said if you don't really have
the wherewithal to
make it like super it's like so awesome
that like nobody could forget it which
you know that's rare come on um then
just make it like so ridiculous that
everyone's just gonna like
be like what the [ __ ] did i just watch
yeah
that's more entertaining to me they're
all go their dj maniac is going holy
[ __ ] was that [ __ ] show you're gonna
like our review
maniacs it was a [ __ ] show i mean to be
honest other day on to be i watched a
rift tracks
of a movie called what the [ __ ] was the
name of that
god monster of indian flats
it was about
a sheep monster kind of
it was a mutant sheep but i kind of felt
like it needed more mutant sheep
because i felt like most of it was just
about a bunch of characters that i
couldn't decide
if they were actually
[Music]
cosplaying
like being in the old west or if it was
flashbacks to the old west i wasn't
entirely sure hugo saw him in malignant
for a second time he liked it even more
i was thinking that too i was thinking
if i saw it again i feel like this might
yeah this might benefit from a second
viewing
we'll see um as well like i said there's
some other [ __ ] coming out i want to see
like antlers is coming out finally like
in october i'm very excited about that
love the wendigo movies and it's
guillermo del toro is involved
so i've been waiting like a year and a
half to see that [ __ ] and i'm also very
excited about what's that one called
last night in soho
that looked super weird i also want to
see venom too and venom two is coming
out philbrin says i can't wait for code
to lay low so i can get myself to new
york city for party weekend uh no just
do what you're gonna do covets never
gonna end that's not part of the plan
but then if you look at the world
economic forum and [ __ ] the guys that
are involved who have been pushing this
through their [ __ ] lat keys that have
taken over
certain government positions in the
western world the idea is to collapse
communi to collapse capitalism and bring
in the new green deal it's not gonna end
so best thing to do is just ignore it
it'll only end when you ignore it stop
just disobey don't worry about that [ __ ]
it will last forever
james look at me like oh you're talking
about man when this [ __ ] started it was
two weeks to save the curve this and
that it's nearly two years on and
they're still playing this [ __ ] game
and there's not enough people dying to
worry me i mean i'm gonna die anyway i
don't give a [ __ ]
there's this is not a [ __ ] pant a
real pandemic a real pandemic don't
start tom dinner piling up don't start
and [ __ ] it's making all right
mortality rates go up and you can
[ __ ] see it is not what you think it
is it's your show now it is my show go
ahead and go bathroom
it is not what it is that's not what
they say it is
if i've seen prisoners of ghost land i
don't know that but i didn't see that
one
exactly an engineer collapse is that
it's a depopulation program
yeah
yeah you you can hand in debate people
and it probably kills them
yeah
it's just not enough of them to make a
difference
people are born all the time
you can just absorb casualties forever
if you look at the average age of the
dead it's 72.
now when you
start giving a [ __ ] bunch of [ __ ]
this given that
then they'll die and then they'll say
well we got to do more of it it's
inventing a pandemic
are you done being smarter than everyone
else i'm smarter than everybody else yep
okay the smarter they think they are the
dumber they are
so you must be the dumbest person ever
because you think you're smarter than
everyone yeah yeah no no good use this
give me another drink tell me what to do
you're gonna do it anyway
[Laughter]
please don't lose time honestly
oh my god
i was just kind of like nope go to the
bathroom bye
ah jesus christ all right
yeah well i got vaccinated but you know
some people won't
anyway
yeah i'm okay so like i said we did a
review about malignant
which we saw on when did we see it
monday monday afternoon
and
i know that it's in the horror community
it seems like at least from my
kind of uh
survey of all the channels that i
subscribe to
seems like a little divisive and i get
that but like i said at least
and i'm not like i said i'm not a big
james wan stan i'm not kind of like i
liked the conjuring it was fine
the conjuring universe movies
are fine they're just kind of
i don't get like all the
you know i don't get all the james one
dick sucking i don't really you know
what i mean i don't get all of that
because the movies are like fine they're
like better than some of the other ones
in the genre but i've seen
better and worse ones than that so it's
just kind of like
i kind of thought like from the trailer
that this was gonna be
another one like that
so the fact that he just went like [ __ ]
it i'm just going like full-on it's just
gonna be like weird cheesy i was just
kind of like all right
i like that i like i like
i like that you did that so you know
what i mean
so i was kind of like conflicted about
it what movie thomas
the one we just saw malignant
like i said we already like it we
already did a review of it so i don't
really want to like rehash it but
i'm just saying and i'm not and i'm not
saying that it's like i'm just some big
james wan fan cause i'm not
i don't hate his movies i don't love his
movies
i like the conjuring but
honestly if you if you ask me like what
are my favorite horror movies the last
20 years
i don't know if the conjuring would be
on there it's good but it wasn't like
super good good it wasn't like super
memorable to me
it was just like
pretty good it was just one of those
like oh that was pretty good that was
entertaining but i didn't like remember
much about it
and i rewatched it again like a little
bit later on i can see it's like higher
production value but
i see a lot of movies like that
well in a way
i i sound like i'm complaining but
in a way that's probably a good thing
because
even mediocre movies nowadays
i mean the production value on them is
so good
because the technology is so much
cheaper nowadays
that like even somebody with not a lot
of money can make
a pretty decent
movie that's like pretty entertaining
for not a lot of money and i think
that's a good thing
but
you know am i to remember that a year or
two from now probably not
but
malignant i probably will remember
because that was some crazy [ __ ]
although not as crazy as some people
because like i said i didn't
i didn't want to say that because i i
kind of feel like it was a spoiler
but
was this you guys if you if you saw it
you probably know what i'm talking about
was this not almost
the same plot as a certain stephen king
novel
that was made into a movie
with i think timothy hutton in it
was that like that was a pretty similar
plot right
am i remembering that wrong
and there was also like a certain 80s
movie
directed by a certain person who may or
may not have also directed frankenhooker
um
that
was kind of sort not exactly the same
plot but similar
similar premise
not the same plot but the similar
premise
i'm just saying so it's not like a
totally original but i did like that he
kind of went like [ __ ] balls to the
wall with it
everybody's timing each other out what's
going on
oh you're doing that yeah i'm talking
about why are you doing it because i
can't
why are you doing why though discuss
cause somebody hurts your feelings nah
why though i don't know
what do you mean you don't know
talking about science and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] i don't hear about science oh
you don't want to hear about science
because you don't believe that i know
science is whatever people say it is um
no that's not how that works that's not
how that works you can lie about science
all day long that's not how that works
though
that's what i think
um no one cares what you think though
because
i need to do i
well that's good because nobody cares
what you think science is now an opinion
it's not though yeah it's not yeah i
don't think it is either words still
mean things
no you can change the definition of
words okay well just argue they're just
doing whatever they want to do
okay they do whatever they want to do
they tell you whatever they want you to
think
i would never trust any of these
[ __ ] none of them
okay whatever okay beowulf says tommy
anyone who is in authority has lied
their way into an authority okay awesome
yeah uh somebody's asking what films
would you want to be remade
honestly i'm i've always been the of the
opinion
if they made a movie
really good the first time
don't remake it
if they made a movie that was a good
idea
but they didn't have the budget or the
talent to pull that [ __ ] off the first
time
then that's right for the picking
so
i would like to see
honestly i know so weird this is kind of
out there
honestly i would like to see somebody do
a decent
fairly
decent budgeted
version of manos the hands of eight
because
one
that was a good idea for a horror movie
two the dude that made it was a
fertilizer salesman and made it for like
thirty dollars
couldn't even do sync sound or anything
i know that movie is like a cult classic
because it's so [ __ ] bizarre
but i think there's a kernel of a good
story in there i think you could make a
good movie out of that
i kind of feel like there's more
justification
for making
a remake of something like that
than doing a remake of like the texas
chainsaw massacre which
was a good movie the first time
so why do we need to make it again and
it's not going to be as good
because honestly
remember back in the early 2000s like
late new 90s early 2000s they were
remaking
all of the 70s and 80s horror movies
they made [ __ ]
nightmare on elm street they remade
friday the 13th they remade pretty much
everything from back in the day
and some of them were okay
like some of them were decent the texas
chainsaw massacre remake was fine it was
fine
but
it wasn't as one it wasn't as good as
the original
um
it just didn't capture the same kind of
[ __ ] it was just like a generic
horror movie so
why bother i mean i know why they
bothered because
you know the intellectual property
um you know everybody knew that name so
it's just kind of like yeah we're gonna
do that but it's just kind of like
you're not gonna do it any better you're
not gonna do anything different
it's just it's not gonna
just make a new thing that's sort of
like that if you're gonna go that route
you know what i mean
i kind of feel like it's better to take
something that
is sort of like a cult classic from back
then but wasn't really that great or
they didn't have a lot of money to
realize the vision
now we have more money now we have more
technology and we could remake it in a
way that
you know well we were talking about this
when we were um
reviewing man who fell to earth
which you know is going up on
well if you're a patron it'll go up
tomorrow morning but if you're not it'll
go friday morning
and we reviewed that and i was like that
was an awesome movie
in some ways
but
i kind of feel like in a lot of ways
that's one that could kind of like be
remade
with nowadays technology
and tighter edit
more narrative structure
and that actually might be really good
that actually might be really good as a
series to be honest with you
based on the original model
but you know
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] that i think was
like more like missed potential don't
take something good
that was good the first time texas
chainsaw massacre friday the 13th or
cary or something like that
and like try to remake that for a new
younger audience it's it's not gonna
work out it's not gonna work out thank
you mango
drunky says yeah
why are you blocking everybody i'm just
playing not black and blue yeah you are
time it out
i see it time it out message deleted by
tom 13 o'clock yeah
tied it up why are you doing that
just because
he says i don't care if you tying me out
i'm not a patron anyway so i was like
it's okay see i don't care
[Laughter]
why you being such a douche
you're really being a douche tonight
what's your problem
you on the rag or something
you on your testosterone bag
let me get a drink hold on
yeah go get another drink shut up
thank you david interesting yeah it's
just i don't know
i'm not averse to remix i'm not what
it's like i like
i don't know i'm an open-minded horror
fan i like all
genres i like all eras depend if if it's
a good movie
it's all good
i'm not averse to remakes
just
you know
just saying oh it's a remake oh i'm not
going to watch it
if it's good fine but
a lot of movies i don't think need to be
remade because they did them all right
the first time
now there are exceptions to that role
i will say like i was one of the big
uh you know
naysayers about when they were talking
about oh we're gonna remake suspiria
because i was kind of like [ __ ]
why would you remake suspiria because
i'm just kind of like one
that movie has like such a distinctive
style
and it's like if you remade it the same
way it would be derivative but if you
made it different it would be like
what's the point
so i was kind of like i don't understand
what the point of that would be but then
when they did the remake in 2018 or
whatever that was
and i was kind of like they went a
different direction with it but kind of
the same story and i was kind of like
oh
okay
okay so that could be done i don't think
they necessarily had to call it suspiria
because it was
sort of the same story but it wasn't
exactly the same
so they could have probably just called
it something else
and they just said it was like an homage
to that and
you know but
i wasn't mad about it you know what i
mean because i thought that was a good
movie in its own right even though it
wasn't
i don't know like i said that's kind of
an example i bring up a lot because
suspiria is a movie that is so
tied to its era and it's so tied to its
visual aspect that to remake it to me
seemed
strange because most of the reason that
people like it is because of how it
looks and the direction
and if you don't have that
then it's not going to be the same you
know what i mean yes
candy man was disappointing
it was all right i mean
i liked a lot of things about it i wish
it had been gorier
like i wish
you know what i mean i wish they the
kills would have been more on screen
it was a cheap cash grab if you ask me
and i think it could have been
i think like some of the characters that
were killed could have been integrated
better into the storyline rather than
just being like random ass there were a
bunch of good ideas but it just didn't
it just didn't it didn't jail
and i mean well philbert's saying that
it's like they did candy but again it
wasn't a remake it was a sequel yeah
sequel so it's just look and honestly
this is actually the third candyman
sequel because they did a second one
which was okay i remember that being
pretty good the third one i hadn't seen
but i've everyone told me it sucked so i
didn't bother watching it so this is
basically like the third one but they're
acting like the other two didn't happen
look we went to the [ __ ] we went to
the movies for [ __ ] two years
straight on that a list okay
there's a pattern and the pattern is
getting stronger and stronger
there's only going to be maybe about 10
really good movies of the year
all right
the rest of them will be forgettable
but i kind of feel like that's
oh that's it's always always been like
that
but
the problem is is that
when you have so many okay movies
that's [ __ ] studio system cannot make
enough money
to continue to run at the profit margins
that they want
because they just can't compete with
streaming services and netflix and the
demographics
have changed it's younger audience now
and they didn't grow up
with a theater culture
they grew up with a cell phone culture
it's on it's it's a dying [ __ ]
genre
well people are just not they're not
tied to the idea of we have to go to a
place and watch a movie you can just
watch whatever movie you want whenever
you want you just look at just follow
the money all right it's just not
something we grew up with yeah
you know just look at the money
when the when the video gaming scene
beats the hollywood scene by many times
over
that's just telling you something
all right
and some people will be like well wait a
minute movies that's a big part of our
culture well a big part of western
culture used to be epic poems you don't
have [ __ ] reading poems anymore
well movies are still a part of the
culture it's just that people aren't
seeing them in the same way and you
don't have and you don't have [ __ ]
like [ __ ] musicals and big [ __ ]
orchestras
uh doing doing [ __ ] operas anymore i
mean you did in the early 1900s but that
[ __ ] was retro back then
uh movies are gonna go that same way
they'll be around
i don't think they'll be
shown in theaters
well like i said there's still movies
and that's still a big part of the
culture and they're still series that's
part of the culture it's just people are
the only thing that's different is the
way that people are consuming that
that's right
right phil says i'm just waiting for
them to remake amityville horror uh
spoiler alert they did um they remade it
in 2000 what was that 2006
2008
was ryan reynolds in that why do i want
to say ryan reynolds was in that
yeah they remade it
and actually the remake i saw the remake
and it was
oh jesus it's just too hot man are you
trying to get attention no it's too hot
for this [ __ ] hair oh no one's paying
attention to tom so he has to do it
shut up [ __ ]
it's just go ahead everybody says they
did candyman again it's not it's not a
remake it's a sequel
it was a sequel i'm just like i'm not
i'm just saying it was a sequel it
wasn't it wasn't a remake um but yeah
they did remake amityville horror
um but i can't remember what it was i
feel like it was like the mid-2000s
the mid to late 2000s please somebody
correct me
um i thought ryan reynolds was in it but
i may be like
confusing him with somebody that looks
like him because all those kind of kind
of white dudes look the same
so
no they do so i was just kind of like
it might have been him he might have
been playing like the [ __ ] the the
crazy person role but
it was i saw it it was all right um it
didn't
i don't know it that's the thing it
didn't like give me the same vibe that
the original did but that might have
been just because i grew up in the 70s
and so like i have like an attachment to
it because that movie scared the crap
out of me when i was a little kid but
you know what i mean but they did remake
it i'm just saying um
now one review that i did
and it's gonna go up
next what am i thinking not not this
saturday is it this saturday
or next saturday i can't remember
but um
i did a review of like the haunting from
1963 which is one of my favorite movies
ever now i will say they remade that in
1999
and that
i saw that in the theater
and that [ __ ]
was
a war crime
i mean
if okay if any of y'all have read the
original shirley jackson novel and you
saw the original movie from 1963
and then you watched the 1999 remake
what the [ __ ] were those people like
what
what happened there
because every the whole point
of the book and the original movie
was that
we're leaving it ambiguous mostly
whether
this haunting it's like the haunting is
real but it's like we're not sure how
much of it is attributable to
this woman that's being like her mental
illness and all of a sudden so we're
leaving it ambiguous and it's like much
better that way
the 1999 one
was a giant
cgi
like wankfest
and it was the [ __ ] worst i saw i
went to saw it in the theater and i was
kind of like
i'm sitting there watching it being like
could this be the stupidest thing that
i've ever seen maybe
maybe
oh i was so mad and i think i said this
in the review i was kind of like
when i saw this in the theater i was
like this might have been the first time
that i actually want to walk into the
theater the second time was probably
like the rob zombie remake of halloween
because that really made me mad
that was the second time that a remake
really made me mad because rob zombie oh
we're gonna give like michael myers a
backstory where he was abused child [ __ ]
off please don't do that don't do that
don't you know anything christ
what was scary about michael myers
no one knew anything about him he's
mysterious that's what's scary
don't like make me sympathize
don't make him like a little kid that
was beaten up by his mom
and oh we feel bad about it now
why are you doing that don't you blah
rob zombie of all people should know
better
why aren't you wearing a shirt
got hot
why is your hair all like foot why why
do you have like a thing of hair like i
can't control the [ __ ] anymore man
where's the brush no [ __ ] it no [ __ ] i'm
just gonna let it let it be like it is
what poop
what you wanna go out
i thought she was out already she came
back in you come back in
yeah yeah
okay yeah hugo says the original
haunting is great the original haunting
is
easily easily one of my favorite horror
movies ever and the reason that it's one
of my favorite horror movies ever is
because it doesn't hardly show anything
it leaves most of the [ __ ] to the
imagination which to me is like much
scarier
well you know that can go too far in the
other direction where they don't show
enough and you're just kind of like okay
well
nothing's happening and i'm like not
scared but i think this like struck a
good balance and i think it was like a
good adaptation of the
um
when they remade it in 1999
and it had like big stars and it had
like [ __ ] liam neeson was in it
um owen wilson was in it
um catherine zeta jones was in it
who said uh lily taylor was in it yeah
yeah so they were the ones and it's like
they changed the premise a little bit
so they come to the house
like the set design was nice but
they changed the whole uh motivation for
them being there which i don't know why
they did that
but they made everything
super
like cgi obvious like it's like oh we're
gonna have this curtain billow out into
a face and like talk to you and i'm like
really are we really
doing that because i kind of feel like
the whole point of
i don't know the whole point of the
original story was that it was like
subtle [ __ ] it was subtle
and like the 90s one
see this is why i don't like a lot of
the horror that came out in the 90s
it didn't appreciate subtlety everything
was like had to be very obvious
very out front we're gonna make
everything look like shitty cgi monsters
and
cgi silhouettes coming out of the wall
talking to you and it's like
i i just can't i just can't with that
i just can't with that
[Music]
yeah phil said like the bending of the
door scene and i love i love in the
original haunting
that that was really the only physical
manifestation that you saw was this door
kind of like breathing
going in and out like that a very simple
effect
and honestly most of it was like sound
design and cinematography and i thought
that was [ __ ] great
great
nobody watch the tape right now where
tom's going to walk through your screen
and off him
oh you put your shirt back on yeah and
he took your wig off
what were you thinking you thought you
were like gonna go back to like nature
or something
or whatever it was you were doing
hugo says that's why i'm afraid of what
rob zombie
might do with the monsters remake
that's why i'm really in bible look i
love rob zombie okay
but
man when he remained halloween
i was excited before it came out
and then i went to see it and i'm like
rob zombie
i thought you were a horror fan i
thought you understood
and
it just i that's why i think that's why
that made me really mad because i
thought that
somebody that was that into horror
which he is would understand that
you don't
demystify your monster you don't
demystify your villain like that
it makes them less scary it makes them
less menacing i mean duh
so
the fact that he didn't know that and he
made a whole movie about
oh look michael myers is this kid and he
was abused by
you know my girlfriend that i put in
every [ __ ] movie
i'm not complaining she's cute and
everything but he does put her in every
movie
and hugo says that's why i'm afraid of
it yeah that's
i'm afraid of that too i'm afraid of
that too we'll see
but
i don't know man i don't know we'll see
how it goes
phil says they don't leave anything to
the imagination anymore
yeah
i'm telling you it's a well
i will say as a horror writer myself
it's a hard balance to strike
you have to
leave enough to the imagination
that people are still invested because
they're like oh what's going on this is
mysterious
you have to leave enough mystery
to
get people interested
but you can't leave it too ambiguous or
people will just be like pissed off like
i don't even know what was going on that
didn't mean anything blah blah so it's
like a really hard
line to walk
so i get it
i'm not gonna like [ __ ] on horror
filmmakers that
come down too much on one side of the
other because
it's a hard you know it's a hard balance
to strike i'm not saying that i'm a
horror runner myself i know
but
don't like i said one of the things that
i feel like is really
in horror
i feel like
the unknown is the scariest
you can't leave it unknown forever
but
you do have to like leave it ambiguous
enough for a long enough time that
people are intrigued and people are
scared by it because they don't exactly
know what it is
but you can't leave it so vague
that people are like i don't even know
what the [ __ ] is going on and i don't
care click and they turn it off
so
i get it's a hard balance to strike
you know i'm so i'm not hating
i don't know if i could do any better to
be honest with you don't know
um
because somebody
who asked me somebody asked me like what
would it
jen you should write a movie
um
i don't know i don't know if i'd be good
at it
i'm you know i read a lot of horror
stories but i don't know
i don't know i don't i don't know how
great they are i write [ __ ] that i like
i don't know if other people would like
it or not so i don't know how good that
would be
[Music]
but
horror is hard to do
i kind of feel like horror
and comedy
are like the two hardest things
you know what i'm saying
it's kind of like
even though i kind of feel like a lot of
people think horror is easy because
oh it's like well we're gonna do it
because it's like cheap
we can just do some cheap jack
zombie movie or like ouija shark or
something like that
we'll do some [ __ ] with like some stupid
special effects
but if you want to do like effective
horror or effective comedy
i think those two things
are equally hard to do because
they're both essentially two sides of
the same coin they're all
build up build up build up release you
know what i mean and you have to like
know
you have to be really good at like the
timing of that stuff to get it right
and if you don't get it right
it's gonna fail miserably
and you know what's the matter nothing
what's matter with you nothing
oh
are you sighing at me no
okay no
no
david june says you can always tell when
tom gets drunk he starts rubbing on his
neck and looking around
in about 10 minutes
jenny doesn't know this yeah i do you
know
well you always look bored when i'm
talking no no so it's kind of like
i'm just listening to this and you're
going you know talking about movies and
and
like i said
you just have to
you just have to look at the [ __ ]
past few years of how everything's are
going and how things are trending
the future is not movies the future is
video games or series
that's really where it's at
but like i said nobody said like movies
are still a thing it's just kind of like
series are just like longer movies i'm
not even sure if movies are a thing some
movies are a thing
but uh you know the information i'm
getting by watching people who actually
are in the industry i don't think movies
are a thing they're not making money
uh a lot of times the producers are
somebody that's fronted the movie and
kind of like a vanity project
through a studio
um
they kind of make the movie they want
the way they want to do it
they'll even [ __ ] tell the people who
have written the script and the
director's no no i don't like that do it
this way the movie comes out it doesn't
really recoup but the person that made
it doesn't care because they already had
a [ __ ] ton of money anyway and i think
it might have something to do with money
laundering
they have to spend a certain amount of
money because they made money somewhere
else talking about the producer
so i'm not sure how legit most movies
are
financially
we're talking artistically yeah a lot of
most of them are mediocre and we know
that they've been mediocre for decades
most of them
movies were actually um
the thing that was around before
television
television came out and [ __ ] really
hurt them
um
but because they had bigger budgets and
bigger production all the way up to the
70s and the 80s movies tended to look
better than television and we know that
i mean look at some of those television
series battlestar galactica was supposed
to be you know competing for star wars
and when you looked at it it kind of
didn't wasn't able to do that
but now because of technology a [ __ ]
television series or a netflix series
can't beat a movie
and actually do a lot deeper
storytelling well to be honest with you
i'm just like when you say movies i'm
kind of like integrating
to be honest movies and tv series are
the same medium to me because it's still
film it's still filmmaking
so you're still telling a story in a
long form visual format
so i don't think that's going anywhere
i'm just saying that i think it will be
more
integrated with other media
that's one thing that will happen when
you say movie to me i'm thinking in
theater 19 no no no that's not how many
minutes that's what i'm thinking a movie
is no that's not anything else
it doesn't any it doesn't have anything
to do with like a theater showing okay
um to me movies and series are kind of
like the same thing yeah series are just
like a longer movie
okay
all right then that made it like like i
said because you're going on about to me
and i'm thinking about in the theater 90
minutes
yeah but that's not what i'm talking
about and i'm talking about filmmaking
just as a general
multimedia
the same thing and like i said movies
and tv series to me are kind of like the
same thing
it's a visual storytelling now i guess
but it wasn't
no i know that but that's how i think of
it
from a creative point of view
that's how i see things when you say
movie i'm thinking of jaws
poltergeist [ __ ] like that when you say
well that's because you're an old person
yeah i think right when you think of
[ __ ] television you're thinking what
knight rider or some [ __ ] like that
i'm not that'll start but you're an old
person yeah but
but the thing is is that none of that's
really happening anymore there is no tv
i know that's why i don't think i don't
think of things like that anymore so
you're talking about a series like a
netflix series which i think that's more
of the future but like i said to me that
just like is like a long movie
yeah i guess so because it's the same
thing it's just longer
yeah i guess
yeah i don't really see it that way i
didn't i was kind of [ __ ]
raised to think of a movie as something
you right but for you well to be honest
like i said
i'm seeing things from an artistic
standpoint from a writer's standpoint
from a visual storytelling it's all
visual storytelling it doesn't really
matter how long it is
so whether it's a movie
or whether it's a series that's kind of
the same thing i think the hollywood
movie the series is just longer
i think the hollywood movie format
in theater
is going i think that's going out
it may be but like i said as long as
people are still making visual medium
media for people to watch
then that's
movie making
still
you know what i'm saying okay i don't
care if they're showing it in theaters
or not okay
like i said it's
the fact that the showing in theaters
now that everybody has streaming yeah
it's really not a relevant discussion
i like seeing things in theaters to just
to me it's not that doesn't like define
the medium though
[Music]
yeah because phil says i think that
movies are on their way out thanks to
netflix and prime services thank you but
like i said
netflix and prime are making their own
movies though and making their own
series and so like i said
if you're talking about movies as in
we're opening it it has to be theater
only yeah but i don't think but i don't
see things like that because
even movies that played in the theater
back in the day would eventually play on
tv
or eventually so
i just see things as like is that a
visual medium
there's over a hundred like a series or
like a movie that's going to play on
like tv or cable or whatever it is it
doesn't have to play in the theater
because a lot of movies
didn't play any theater they came out
straight to there's over a hundred years
of [ __ ] cinema
and cinematic history
it was done in a theater with a
projector and it was [ __ ] about 90
minutes and it was a story that was
wrapped up pretty quickly it wasn't a
series you could have a trilogy like
star wars or other things you know i
mean you have something like jaws one
two and three and all that kind of crap
if you want to say that that's a [ __ ]
series with [ __ ] continuity and i
don't really think it is but to me good
lord john's three yeah but to me
a movie was a self-contained story in
about 90 minutes to two hours that you
sat in a theater and watched
a series like say walking you know
walking dead no not really a movie
that's a series now is it cinematic i
think it's better than a movie actually
but that's what i'm saying it's all like
to me
yeah that's all visual
yeah it's all the visuals
so to me it doesn't there's no
distinction for me between me there's an
extent
a series i don't there's no distinction
to me there's a distinction because
you're not gonna really see walking dead
in a theater
you'd be in there for [ __ ] ever
or you'd have to go over and over again
i'm just saying that that theater format
is not going to survive
right but what i'm saying now will the
theater survive it might maybe but i'm
just saying that
the fact that you could watch a movie in
a theater
that doesn't have anything to do with
the product itself because you could
watch that product in your house
obviously yeah
um so the fact that you're seeing it in
the theater or seeing your house that to
me is immaterial
right um that doesn't have anything to
do with like the the work of art itself
well we're gonna we're just gonna differ
on it that's all i think that the
theater was a different experience
because it started in a large way it is
although lesser nowadays because most
people have pretty good setups in their
own house
movies started before televisions people
couldn't i know people couldn't see it
in their [ __ ] home
how it started was live performances on
stage that goes all the way back to the
14 right there everybody knows actually
they had that [ __ ] back in rome [ __ ]
all the way going back to [ __ ] greece
all right which is live
theater really there wasn't any
difference between a movie and live
theater it's just that [ __ ] in the
movie it's projected on a [ __ ] screen
and you could have special effects
eventually in a [ __ ]
soundtrack an audio track it was kind of
more of an immersive [ __ ] thing but
it was still that same kind of like a 90
minute two-hour format that you had only
going back to ancient greece
a series is a lot longer a lot more
[ __ ] ambitious and they just didn't
have the technology it's almost like
it's a different venue i just i'm just
going to say to me it's a different
venue because the writing of the story
is not as encapsulated it's not as
limited to that 90-minute format of you
sitting there well
honestly as a writer the only difference
is
the difference between a series is like
a novel
and a movie is like a short story
that's the only difference right um so
it's not really it's plays
but it's not a difference in kind it's
the same thing it's just like a movie
was a play
right but it's not
it's really not that different to me
it's just not that different
sorry i just don't see it that
differently a series is a lot more like
a novel
well yeah i know that but i'm just
saying that in that way a movie is like
a short story
i don't see those two things as
different things
you know what i mean all right it's just
a slightly different approach but not
really
okay
um you know that's all
okay um
geriatric punk says joe's revenge is
even worse oh my god i saw jaws the
revenge
in the theater
um
that's the one
with michael kane
and that was the one that was just four
i think
that was the one where
the shark
um remembered the brody family
and followed them to
where'd they move to
i kind of feel like if i was that family
and they were worried about a shark
they would move to like the midwest or
somewhere there wasn't an ocean but of
course
they moved to somewhere where there
still was an ocean like florida
so they moved down there and then the
charlotte tracked them
yeah
and uh
yeah
i saw them in theater yeah david [ __ ]
david wants me to do a video game show
problem with me doing a video game show
is that i can't get through video games
fast enough to do enough shows
to be
commercially viable i mean i'll [ __ ]
spend a lot of long time on one game
all right
like i still haven't gotten through that
new [ __ ] alien game were you playing
ripley's daughter it's pretty good
i mean i can there are some problems
with it but
like you can't [ __ ] fight this thing
and [ __ ] you're playing this girl and
she just can't really fight anything
so everything is about hiding
and that's just the way that character
is written
it's getting kind of annoying to me
um
but
i don't know if i could do a video game
channel
um
i don't know
i i'd have to [ __ ] i don't really
like playing video games that much
he doesn't really have the stamina yeah
i guess the good thing about it i'll
[ __ ] be honest i'll play a couple of
hours and go ah [ __ ] that you know what
i mean now if i was [ __ ] 20 years
younger i was like driven to complete
the get damn game then maybe but most
these games i'm not even really driven
to complete them
i'm like i see where this is going i
don't give a [ __ ] and stuff like this
i don't know what it is when you're
younger you're real curious about how
the thing's going to end and what the
next levels will be
when you get in your [ __ ] 40s and 50s
you don't care as much you don't care
what the game's gonna be it's just
something some [ __ ] wrote
you know
so you i'm not as curious as i was about
how it's gonna end you're no fun tom no
i was more curious
look man i was more curious when i was a
kid on that damn [ __ ] atari [ __ ]
that's why you're old trying to do
[ __ ] because you're not listening to
what she's trying to [ __ ] with
that's why you're old remember that game
adventure when you're on atari and you
find the [ __ ] hidden [ __ ] screen
that had the writer's name in it
you're super curious about because you
don't know the limits of video games
what else is on that [ __ ]
you know or the same thing you're
playing [ __ ] akari warriors
and what's the end how much money is
going to take you to get to the end of
that goddamn thing
you know
and eventually you get to the end of it
and you go okay that's the end
and it's really not much different from
the beginning of it when you look back
on it but when you
but back in those days you were quite
impressed that you got to the end of it
you know
it's just imagery
you know
computer imagery so he's too cool for
that [ __ ] nowadays
[Laughter]
it's not just me i mean [ __ ] that's
one of the reasons why kids don't really
give a [ __ ] about these movies
because it's imagery they grew up with
[ __ ] intense imagery it doesn't
impress them
but [ __ ] when we were seeing these
movies we'd see some of this [ __ ]
badass imagery like someone a blade
runner or [ __ ] alien
and the imagery was [ __ ] like wow
[ __ ] that was super impressive
but
kids of the equivalent age today see
imagery in the movies and they don't
even care it's because imagery their
imagery doesn't impress them they grew
up with that
speaking of which
i'm kind of hoping i don't know if i'm
gonna be like pull this off because
we're moving now
but i'm gonna do
a 31 days of halloween
i decided i was gonna do 31 days
so i'm gonna start doing like movie
reviews
i'm gonna do one movie review every
single day of october
hopefully
we'll see how that goes
i'm going to do
31 movies that i wanted to do for a
really long time and i haven't really
got around to doing
i know tom's gonna like
sneer at me i'm not even listening and
be upset about it i didn't even hear
what you're saying what are you saying
and it'll be stupid but you know what i
mean
it'll be fun
mega badgers says the only movie to
watch for my i'm gonna have a hand
that's not true michael kane had other
good movies no the hand was awesome the
hand was good but he had other good
movies the island was good i really
liked the island
we did reviews of both of those
both of those
yeah [ __ ] october races tom's not old
the older the [ __ ] bull the stiffer
the horn yeah right bro
no she she does that to me when she
wants to [ __ ] [ __ ] with me she calls
me an old man
even though i'm only a couple years
older than her
well i'm old too i'm but i'm not um in
denial about it i'm not denial about it
i'm also old and i'm like not denial
about it i know what happened i know i'm
52. i accept it
[Laughter]
i accept it
so you know
yeah the island was [ __ ] great i
liked the island
david warner was in that shape yeah
although
he was in
honestly i saw david warner in the omen
getting his head cut off by the painted
glass
he was in a lot of movies back in the
day
i loved him in the 70s and then i
realized later that in the 80s
that [ __ ] would be in anything
because i saw a bunch of david warner
well yeah he had bill because
[ __ ] had bills to pay
mystery science theater
did a like medieval
the [ __ ] was the name of that movie they
did some like weird like medieval movie
and a couple of them had david warner in
them and i was kind of like oh david
warner you were in the omen
how did you sink this low no [ __ ] but
then i was kind of like well
[ __ ] gotta eat [ __ ] gotta eat [ __ ]
had bills to pay so i'm not gonna hate
i'm not gonna hate he had an expensive
probably a cocaine habit and [ __ ]
[ __ ] houses to pay for the main
[ __ ]
of course he's going to be in a movie i
can't [ __ ] on the actors too much it's
like i make fun but it's kind of like
richard burton would be look they get a
job like everybody else and they're kind
of like look
i have a you know i made all this money
back in the 70s and i bought this house
and i married this wife and now she's
taking me for all my money look so i
have to like pay all these bills
look don't listen to her look don't
listen to her the deal was this
oh oh
yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] lay this [ __ ] out
so you guys can understand this don't
listen to me tom no listen to her tom
knows better than everybody yeah no i
just know better than her
[ __ ] the british
british actors were the [ __ ]
okay because they came from a system
where you actually had to learn how to
act and go through the theater do some
shakespearean [ __ ] get training that's
not the way
american actors
came into the scene in hollywood they
came into who could blow who how much
coke they could chip into the project
[ __ ] it was it was a lot more shady
all right a lot of those american actors
were not trained they made they were
making [ __ ] up but a british actor was
trained
well hollywood i've always said no i'm
not going to lay you wait
when do you ever let being no no no no i
just laid the first thing down i'm
laying down the groundwork for what was
coming next
the british actors were trained
but they came from england
they didn't have a whole lot of money
so you could hire these trained actors
for your project and they would class up
the joint
and that's what hollywood used these
british and [ __ ] mango beds he's
going to jump in because that's right
that's what happened
hollywood would hire british actors to
class up the [ __ ] joint and they
didn't pay him all that much
not compared to some
american hottie girl who was [ __ ]
cassie couch and blowing dudes for the
million dollars weinstein and the
[ __ ] they didn't they you know i
mean so they would bring in these
british dudes alec guinness and [ __ ]
like can you act no yeah yeah well you
do you have nice titties yeah okay then
you're gonna be tired exactly that's
exactly
but they'd [ __ ]
warner [ __ ] you'd bring in [ __ ]
michael caine you'd bring in [ __ ]
richard burton and and [ __ ] alec
guinness and they would class your
project most of them okay i'm mostly
talking about uh oliver reed here yeah
we're too drunk to know what was going
on oliver
don't get me started on oliver reed
i'm just saying
no no hate against alcoholics i'm super
drunk right now yes i'm just saying that
oliver reed was
the best british drunk you could get
for the money
he would show up class up the joint he
was scary when he was fighting would he
show up maybe yeah he he could act
when he showed up he'd be awesome and he
would seem super serious and then while
you weren't watching he'd [ __ ] take
his clothes off and walk down the street
and go to the [ __ ] bar and get
arrested you never knew yeah he would do
some [ __ ] it was a surprise
but everybody loved it everybody loved
it oh we know you you're that british
actress yes yes um all of it
okay we're not gonna arrest you we're
gonna take you back to the [ __ ] yeah
that
and that that's you're white enough and
rich enough you can get away with all
kinds of shenanigans
[Laughter]
but i gotta hand that to the british the
british actors [ __ ] um classed up a
lot of american movies
they did yeah
even when david warner
in
what the [ __ ] movie was that i saw it on
mst it was like some medieval [ __ ]
um
even when he was peeing in a pan and
throwing in a wizard
he was still managing to class up the
place
yeah
we love you david warner yeah
honestly i first saw david warner in the
omen
and then he was in
time after time
we did a review of that yeah yeah yeah
everybody go watch time after time yeah
good movie from 1979 one of my favorite
favorite movies ever
jack the ripper meets h.g wells there's
time travel involved
it's really really good
um but yeah
so
it kind of made me sad
david june jumps in and says rick from
the walking dead yeah there's yeah he is
[ __ ] great too there's another
british actor you would know that dude
is british andy lincoln i'm southern and
he got that accent right he got it
pretty right well everybody that saw
love actually knew that he was british
although i didn't see that because i
didn't i didn't i didn't like chick
flicks i didn't know i didn't know he
was british and i was going like where'd
they get this is that [ __ ] where's
that dude from he sounds like he's from
[ __ ] mississippi or alabama
it sounded like a [ __ ] you know i
bought it he's he was good he his accent
was [ __ ] spot on now sometimes you
know with him talking about coral it's
not quite that strong
but
i thought it was a southerner acting
you know what i mean
he's acting
but no i bought that one if you put him
right next to [ __ ] a real southern
actor like [ __ ] rooker michael rooker
that's a real mississippi [ __ ]
right there okay and
there wasn't that you didn't see a big
difference between the two
you know what i mean you you can and i
can believe that those two guys were in
this from the same speculated about this
why is it
that british actors
in general
can do a better
american accent
uh american actors
cannot do a british accent okay i don't
think i've ever well somebody please
correct me i'll tell you what have you
ever seen an american actor do a better
southern accent british accent okay then
a british actor has done an american no
no i gotta think it trying to do a
british accent it's always been it's
always like every time i hear it i'm not
even british so i'm just kind of like
oh yeah yeah
you know i'm always kind of like this
the whole time it goes back to what i
was saying all right
no boy in there he's mad at me because i
[ __ ] timed him out but he's got
[ __ ]
he's got acting don't time people out oh
no i tell my [ __ ] out when i
want to have a [ __ ] i'm drunk
i'm drunk i'll time your [ __ ] ass out
okay you have too much power no power
power is going to be abused that's how
it's going to be
you know i'm not about justice this is
injustice all right that's it
i'm going to take your time
playing i'm taking your tablet away but
look looking um i got theatrical
training too
and actually and [ __ ] grandpa's
hammer who's in there we went to the
same [ __ ] high school we had a really
good drama teacher
she was crazy as [ __ ] but it was
classical training it was kind of like
what the british would get
um them even better because they would
go into the shakespearean stuff all
right
um
the reason why the british can do it is
because they do total immersion
and they [ __ ] will get coaches and
they will actually be well they take it
seriously yeah they're taking a serious
thing but actually become a person from
another country that's what they're
doing
the [ __ ] accent and everything
[ __ ] it it's kind of like method
acting but better there's
you can just do a total immersion and
just become another person is it good
for your mental health no it isn't
at all
[ __ ] um
and even all west's name dude who played
[ __ ] hannibal lecter will tell you
that acting if you really acting real
acting is bad for your mental health
what's his name um
guy who played hannibal lecter um
wait which one in the movie or the
series the movie
um anthony house kevin hopkins
well he's he's good even though if you
ask me he's always
played himself a lot he's playing
himself really he's earned it yeah but
he can
that's another one that they hire to
class up the [ __ ] joint
all right but um
so he'll know what i'm talking about
they're they're using kind of like a
total immersion technique where they'll
get a voice coach and they'll [ __ ]
train over and over and over again to
get that accent right
a [ __ ] your average american
working out of hollywood
um in a [ __ ] b movie
won't even give a [ __ ]
they'll just fake it yeah i do kind of
feel like just to get the work out of
the way and then on the next project
they don't give a [ __ ] the american like
and i'm not
i don't know i'm generalizing a little
bit
but the american way kind of
not everybody
the american way is kind of to like
let's find the easiest way to like get
around this yeah uh with this little
work as possible
um we don't want to like make anything
good we just want to like make it as
we want to make it look good but with as
little work as possible
that's what i'm saying yeah
so i worry about money and drugs and
time
yeah so i kind of feel i don't know if a
lot of american actors would put in the
same kind of like and that's what i mean
what i mean a lot of british actors
take they take that craft
more seriously
than an american actor would
generally i'm not saying everybody camp
guy generally he can't guy mention peter
o'toole that was another [ __ ]
that could class up the joint and [ __ ]
if you ever seen him in [ __ ] a man
called horse and return of a man called
horace i love peter
yeah he did a great job and the the
man of called horses about [ __ ] a
dude who a british dude who gets uh
[ __ ] abducted by a a native american
indian tribe and he becomes an indian he
goes [ __ ] that's what they call it back
in the day and there's all kinds of
[ __ ] wild [ __ ] happens it's a great
movie i can't find man called horse but
i can find return of a man called horse
i don't know what maybe uh copywriting
or something about the ownership of that
movie i wanted to buy it i remembered it
as a kid a man called horse you can't
find it
kind of a lost movie
uh but it had all kinds of weird native
american rituals of [ __ ] hanging
people from the lodge polls with the
[ __ ]
you know the
bear claws through their [ __ ] skin
they were doing suspension like like uh
like aurora does
using [ __ ] bear closets remember that
did you ever see that movie yeah it's
pretty good a long time a long time ago
yeah
camp guy says i think the snl cast gets
voice lessons singing lessons yeah i
kind of feel like
if you're gonna be in entertainment you
kind of like
you know it on a large scale you kind of
need that
um
philbert says i prefer method acting you
have to dig deep inside yourself to feel
the part you play
yeah i get that
i get that like everybody likes to [ __ ]
on
um actors like
trying to think of like a famous method
actor
daniel day-lewis let's say that
um
he's like look i'm gonna just be the
character nobody talk to me
you know what i mean
um
i get that that's like easy to make fun
of but
i get it
i kind of feel like if i was an actor
which i'm not
because i'm i can't like pretend to be
somebody else it's like
i'm not willing to go there
but
i get that you just want to like immerse
yourself in that
headspace
and just kind of like i'm just gonna
like be this person
and i don't want like anything
i don't remember everything in the
system of method acting all right
um method acting is pretty much
i am this person i am this character so
you have to like respond to me yeah but
then there was more to it than that
there was something about associating
your past [ __ ] emotional responses
with this that too
but there was i remembered
i remembered that it worked but when
you're real young you don't have enough
memories to make these associations
i remember thinking when i was learning
all that that
that method acting was only about half
of it and then for me at that time the
other half was
basically mimicking
what you see other people
doing too it's been a long time
it's a lot of it had to do with blocking
a lot of it had to do with feeding off
the audience there's a senate synergy
between the actor the
the whole cast
and energy coming off of a live crowd
uh which of course you don't have in
movies let's see so it makes it makes a
lot harder
um i think i think when the guys that
are [ __ ] acting in movies a lot of
it's just mechanical because they're
repeating the same things over and over
and over again well to me that would
seem like really hard because
a day of movie shooting is basically
like
well you have to sit around for like
four hours and have like makeup put on
and then you have to go and get like
we have to like have a bunch of angles
of you doing this one scene over and
over again
then you have to
so it i don't know it it would seem like
really hard to like immerse yourself
in that character cam guy says a lot of
it has to do with how an actor is
perceived as well yeah their public
image like you look at tom cruise
tom cruise is all public image and he
pretty much plays himself in every
[ __ ] movie
i can't imagine tom cruise having
yeah a personality
i think tom cruise as in like
a personality other than
the
thing that he's portraying to the world
if you ask me tom cruise's [ __ ]
acting career has kind of suffered
because he's always that it was you know
it's called type casting but the whole
scientology thing and all that's [ __ ]
kind of folded in
and he does have his fans but he's
always gonna
live off of his fans for the rest of his
life
um
which i wouldn't call myself a tom
cruise fan but i like tom cruise and i
will see um
his uh spy movies
every one of them that's came out in the
theater i've seen it what's it called uh
um what the mission mission possible
yeah
yeah i like mission impossible uh some
of those were good yeah i liked his
[ __ ] oblivion
i like to [ __ ] um his science the
science fiction has come out now is he
is he acting no he's more like
performing
he's tom cruise in all of them that's
what i'm saying i make a distinction
between
acting and performing because
if you're acting
i forget that it's you yeah
if you're performing i still remember
that it's you but i'm still kind of
buying you and whatever it is
the closest to acting
out of the good movies that i've liked
that i've seen of him
would have been an interview with the
vampire sometimes i will kind of forget
that that was tom cruise and kind of buy
that that's lestat
that was really overall his best movie
if you ask me yeah i mean to me
the best acting is if i if you're a big
star if i forget that that's you yeah if
i think that that is another person with
tom the only time i've forgotten that
that was him was an interview with the
vampire the rest of his movies that's
[ __ ] tom cruise
but they're paying to see tom cruise so
i understand it sure back in the market
today in those days in those days that
market was paying to see tom cruise
yeah it was pre-internet playing a
different role but it's still tom cruise
and that a lot of that [ __ ] was going on
in the [ __ ] 80s and 90s too
and and so i think artistically it was
the right choice i mean two of the shits
i bring up two of the things i bring up
um
in
you know in the uh effect of like a big
actor
making me forget that that was an actor
yeah it's hilbert phil i said another
thing [ __ ] eyes wide shut you kind of
forget that that's [ __ ] tom cruise i
did not
kinda
i did not kinda he's good in it he is
good in it he's good in it yeah but i
didn't forget that that was tom cruise
it's still tom cruise yeah i guess so i
didn't forget that he still had that
cocky
he still had that maybe he did quality
but that was selling at that time
that was but i don't i never liked that
so it was like to me that was always
kind of like it worked though it made
money it made money and that's what they
were buying to me that was like very
tiresome but okay
i always liked top
i always liked tom even though he's a
tiresome tiresome person yeah he he's
he's a [ __ ] cocky [ __ ] but
that's
that was part of his brand though you
know and
it is on brand yeah i understand i
understand a lot of people didn't like
it but that's that's people were paying
to see that this is pre-internet you
couldn't get sick of a [ __ ] as
fast as you can now to nowadays
and it was just it was it was not as
[ __ ] wide spectrum it was a narrow
spectrum back then
the media the way it was
and i remembered in those days seeing
those movies and and liking it
what the [ __ ]
their [ __ ] message i liking it be
liking it because it was tom cruise
now look
can i like get back to what i was going
to do before you interrupted me
so
thank you unity for me too thomas great
and tropic thunder is less i need to
re-watch this i need to see it yeah you
probably need to watch that because
you'd probably love that jet i feel like
you would love that
two recent well
yeah fairly recent
examples
of actors immersing themselves in their
roles that i forgot who they were
um
martin landau in ed wood
playing bella lugosi
the first time i saw ed wood in the
theater whenever that came out in the
early 2000s
i forgot
that that was an actor
playing bella lugosi
i forgot momentarily that bella lugosi
was no longer alive
so
good job there
oscar robbed
another
thing was the movie about aileen
warner's monster
charlize theron playing aileen warnos
i saw that in the theater
and i forgot
that alien hornets was dead
and that i was not watching her on the
[ __ ] screen
to me
that is
oscar-worthy acting i forgot that was an
actor i forgot the actual person they
were playing was dead i
i thought that i was watching the actual
person
so to me
that seems like it should get the awards
because i forgot
i forgot that that wasn't that actual
person
straw dog says that tom
um on his best movie was second born on
the fourth of july i remember seeing
that but i forgot which one that was
that was okay i remember that it was a
vietnam movie yeah is that the one where
he was like a paraplegic or something
i don't know maybe yeah he was in a way
he was in a wheelchair yeah yeah
i got that one confused with the michael
jake fox one
where they uh he played an actual person
yeah and born on the 4th of july
like i said
there's something about tom cruise when
i see tom cruise i don't want him to see
a play an actual person though
it's just that's his brand i guess even
in the mud that's what i mean i kind of
feel like tom cruise yeah is one of
these
i kind of like arnold
where you're it's not a real person you
get into this like [ __ ] uh
like purgatory
of acting where you're kind of like
i can't play a character because
everyone
knows who i am
um so i can't immerse myself into a role
like no one will buy it
um but it's kind of like i have to like
play myself in a certain way
but
also that's
no one wants to see that either yeah so
it's kind of like a weird
i don't know it's like a weird like gray
area
i don't know
and tom cruise
i saw him in movies in the 80s
and i remember not liking him back then
because it seems like
every character he played was like this
cocky
overconfident douchey
character
and i was just kind of like
i don't like people like that so i was
just kind of like
all right
you're gonna just do that from now on
great
so but when he played like other
characters in later movies i was kind of
like
okay
you can kind of like play a different
kind of character but i still remember
that it's you though
which is unfortunate
but
i will give it
interview with the vampire like
sometimes interview the vampire he was
good in that he was good in magnolia
he's good when he's playing
a dick
when he's playing a villain
he's good like that yeah that's playing
into like his natural
tendencies
right
um when he's playing a good guy
i don't buy it
i don't buy it
you fine
i'm ready to [ __ ] close it down i'm
getting drunk what's uh you want another
drink
no you don't need any more you've had
enough
i don't know you've had enough i would
like some more water please just more
water
but uh no it's almost not it's past nine
it is 9 16 p.m yeah can i have some more
water yeah water
yeah i kind of feel like
i don't know i kind of feel like that's
my i and i'm not saying that like i
don't like these actors that
yeah like johnny depp it's like we know
it's johnny depp he's just johnny depp
being this other person
but
i'm a lot more impressed with an actor
that
as famous as they are
i forget
who they are
like i said i went and saw a monster
in the theater when it came out which
was i don't know when that was early
2000s mid-2000s whenever it was
charlize playing
alien warnos
i saw that in the theater and i forgot
i forgot that aileen wuornos
the actual person
was dead
i thought that i was watching her
on the screen that's how good that [ __ ]
was
so
i kind of feel like that's what you're
aspiring to
like
if you're playing a real person
make me forget
that that is you
so in some ways
when you're an actor and you become as
big as someone like tom cruise or
whoever
it's kind of in a way that's good
because you're making all the money but
it's also like a detriment because
everybody knows you
so you can't lose yourself in a role as
easily so it's much more difficult
because to me it seems like as an actor
you need to lose yourself
i need to forget that that's an actor
and i'm seeing
that character
whoever it is whether it's a real person
or a fictional person
you need to portray that character i
don't need to see you the actor
you know
okay so um i think it's been a good
[ __ ] stream today we're gonna go
ahead and we're gonna wrap it up if you
guys can go ahead and like share and
subscribe well [ __ ] why am i [ __ ] go
ahead and tell you guys to like and
subscribe i mean you guys already
[ __ ] know the deal we're gonna be
back when uh [ __ ] friday before we
back friday night we are gonna be
talking about a super depressing topic
yeah which what are we gonna see unit
731 which one is that japanese warcraft
oh okay yeah yeah yeah
okay i know about that one
all right so you 731 japanese [ __ ]
uh war crimes you're doing medical
experiments and stuff
yeah i remember that it's pretty [ __ ]
weapons experiments is it does this
include the microwave uh weapon
experiments yes they have that one too
yeah yeah it's sitting there just
cooking dudes with microwaves and [ __ ]
all right so we'll uh we can't even like
make jokes about [ __ ] it's like it's so
messed up yeah it depends it's not a
biological weapon
biological experimentation
okay so we'll uh talk to you guys later
we're gonna go inside out
although we will be back yeah we'll be
back friday night yeah talking about
depressing
warframes that's what i said good for
you
but yeah that's what you guys voted for
that's what you guys voted for yeah
that's what they wanted
so what's up we'll see you guys later
all right bye-bye see you guys later bye